TODAY SUB ONE HEARING ON AND WE
WILL START WITH ISSUE ONE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
I COULD HAVE THE FIRST PANEL
COME FORWARD
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY DOOR FOR
CONFLICT.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LARA
CONLEY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WHICH I
BECAUSE TO GO AHEAD TO EVER
AFFECT MONEY.
STEVEN
TRADUCTION. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
DEAN FUJIMOTO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOE RODRIGUEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN.
LOUISE BOURGEOIS DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
LIAM OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JACKIE BURROUGHS CO ILIO.
AND LET ME JUST PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES. A
TWO HUNDRED AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
IN OF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THIRTY FOUR
MILLION UP THAT. IS IN GENERAL
FUND. AS THE DESIGNATED STATE
UNIT ON TEACHING THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERS A VARIETY OF OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS. BOMB
PROVIDING COMMUNITY SERVICES.
UNDER THOSE PROGRAMS AND OF THE
HEALTH INSURANCE COUNSELING AND
ADVOCACY PROGRAM. THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO ADMINISTERS TO MEDI CAL
PROGRAMS HOME COMMITTEE BASED
MEDICAL PROGRAMS THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAMS WE REFER TO AS THAT
MISSISSIPPI. A AND THE COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES PROGRAM SEA
BASS.
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE CTA'S.
FUNDING COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF OUR OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS THE
REMAINING GENERAL FUND IS FOR
OUR MATCH.
FOR THAT FEDERAL FUNDING.
AND IN LOOKING BACK BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN PRIMARILY
THAT FEDERAL FUNDING HAS
REMAINED CONSTANT AND FLAT.
OVERALL IN TERMS OF OUR OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS HOWEVER
IF THE SENIOR EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
AT OUR TOOK A SIX PERCENT CUT
OVER THAT TIME PERIOD. AND THE
HEALTH INSURANCE COUNSELING
ADVOCACY PROGRAM HIGH CAP. ON
TOOK A TWENTY PERCENT REDUCTION.
ON IN THEIR FUNDING. AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF A FEDERAL BUDGET AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE CONTINUE
TO OPERATE UNDER THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTIONS WE KEEP OUR FINGERS
CROSSED FUND. ON ACTION EFFORTS
OCCURRING.
AS WE SPEAK.
THIS IS OUR FIFTH CONTINUING
RESOLUTION.
AND THAT.
THAT EXPIRES ON FRIDAY SO WE
REMAIN CAUTIOUSLY HOPEFUL IN
TERMS OF THAT.
THE PRESIDENT'S BUDGET PROPOSED
LEVEL FUNDING FOR MOST OF THE
OLDER AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS. A
HOWEVER THE HEALTH INSURANCE
LIKE CAP PROGRAM.
AND NIGHT OF SENIOR EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WOULD BE ELIMINATED
UNDER THAT BUDGET.
SO WE.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S A PROPOSAL.
ON ONE OF THE AREAS THAT I KNOW
WAS REFERENCED.
IN THE AGENDA EXTENSIVELY IN A
NUMBER OF THE CHARTS ON THAT
WERE INCLUDED ARE FROM OUR STATE
PLAN ON AGING. AND THAT COVERS
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
BOB THE WAY WE'VE ORGANIZED THAT
PLAN.
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS OR SO IS
THAT WE INCLUDE AN INTRODUCTORY
SECTION THAT REALLY LOOKS
BROADLY AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE SOCIO DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS.
TRENDS THAT WE SEE IN TERMS OF
THE AGING OF THE POPULATION.
AND I THINK THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
FOR ALL A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
PREPARING CONCRETE TO GATHER
DATA THAT'S THAT'S HELPFUL IN IN
IN ONE LOCATION BUT THE
REMAINDER OF THE PLAN ALMOND
ORCHARDS COMPONENT OF IT. I'M
REALLY IS A DOCUMENT THAT WE
NEED TO PREPARE TO RECEIVE OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AGING.
AND.
SO WE DO SO.
LOOKING AT THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
CURRENTLY OPERATE.
AREAS WHERE WE GET RECEIVE
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE ACTION ON.
AS WELL AS AREAS THAT WE THINK.
YOU KNOW NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BUT I JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT WE
DO SO THERE.
BUT DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS DO
PLANS FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES TO
FUTURE PLANS.
OUR PLAN WE DO WITH THE INTENT
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY COMPLETE
THOSE ACTIVITIES.
SO THEY'RE NOT JUST.
KIND OF AMBITIOUS PLANS THAT
WERE THEN TO GO OUT AND LOOK FOR
FUNDING FOR WE REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT BY AND LARGE BASED ON WHERE
THINGS ARE AT THAT POINT IN
TIME.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THOSE ALTHOUGH I MUST
SAY WE ALWAYS ADD A FEW LITTLE
ASPIRATIONAL.
ITEMS THAT WE THINK ARE WITHIN
OUR REACH.
IT WOULDN'T BE A GOOD PLAN
WITHOUT THAT AS WELL.
.
THE OUR FEDERAL FUNDING COMES TO
WAS AS A GRANT
A IT IS NOT AND PROPORTIONATE I
KNOW YOU'VE GOT THAT. WONDERFUL
CHART IN YOUR AGENDA IN TERMS OF
THE GROWTH OF THE POPULATION.
IT DOES NOT COME YOU KNOW AS
THE POPULATION GOES UP.
OR FIND FUNDING DOESN'T
AUTOMATICALLY INCREASE IN
RELATION TO THAT POPULATION IT'S
ONE OF THE FACTORS.
IN TERMS OF HOW THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED TO STATES
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
FACTORS THAT ARE INVOLVED AND
HOW THOSE THOSE FUNDS COME TO
WAS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THEN I JUST WAS GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON IN TERMS OF TALKING
ABOUT TWO OF THE OUR OUR MAJOR
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OF PARTICULAR
I THINK. I'M INTERESTING
DISCUSSION TODAY CERTAINLY THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM. A IS
OUR LARGEST OLDER AMERICANS ACT
PROGRAM.
AND VERY VERY WELL KNOWN AND
PAGE TWELVE SHOWS THE CURRENT
FUNDING FOR BOTH THE HOME
DELIVERED AND NOT CONGREGATE
NUTRITION PROGRAMS BEFORE HAVE
YOU MOVE ON CERTAIN ISSUE ONE I
MADE.
JUST PASSED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ALEJO TO OFFER ANY
COMMENTS AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THE OVERVIEW.
CAPTION IF YOU HAVE ANY TEN
NOTHING AT SEEING NONE WE WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE
IF PEOPLE HAVE ANY.
SORRY JUST TRYING TO BE SYSTEM
AND DON'T KNOW THAT ABSOLUTELY.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
WENDY PETERSON WITH THE SENIOR
SERVICES COALITION OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY. REPRESENTING FORTY.
ON NONPROFIT PUBLIC
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES.
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS
IN OUR COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU THAT
CONT CALIFORNIA'S CONTRIBUTION
TO LOCAL AFFILIATES.
ARM IN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
BUDGET HAS BEEN FLAT FOR A
DECADE. HOME FIFTH OF MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER.
PEOPLE HAS GROWN BY TWO HUNDRED
BY TWO MILLION IN THAT TIME. ON
THIS FLAT FUNDING HAS RESULTED
IN INADEQUATE CAPACITY UNLIMITED
ACCESS ON HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
OUR COUNTY IN SPITE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STEPPING UP AND
PUTTING THEIR FAIR SHARE F
FUNDING.
A FEW INTO SERVICES WE CANNOT
MEET THE NEED ARMED. IT'S TODAY
WERE ASKING THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
UNDER THE FLAT FUNDING.
WHOM WE URGE YOU TO INCREASE
STATE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND ALL THE PROGRAM
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
ARM AND COMMIT YOU KNOW COMMIT
TO ESTABLISHING THAT NEW
BASELINE GOING FORWARD BECAUSE.
SENIORS ARE GOING TO BE HERE.
THESE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING RP
ARE POWERFUL ARM AND EFFECTIVE
AND THEY ARE VITAL FOR THE
SENIORS WHO RELY ON THEM.
IF THE STATE PAYS ITS FAIR
SHARE ORDER CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
ABLE WILL HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO LIVE. SAFELY AND.
THRIVE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT.
BECAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARISSA MELLOW AND I'M WITH
MEALS ON WHEELS OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY. WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO GO
ON THE RECORD AND STATE THAT WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
PROGRAMS AND THESE MAJOR AREAS
NUTRITION. SENIOR COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES SUPPORT
SERVICES COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS AND MEDI
CAL PROGRAMS.
THESE WRAPAROUND SERVICES ARE
CRUCIAL AND VITAL TO THE
VITALITY OF OUR SENIORS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND.
OUR NATION.
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY ARE I AM
HERE TODAY.
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR MORE
FUNDING THAT IS SEVERELY NEEDED
AN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND THROUGH
OUR.
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA THINK
YOU THINK YOU MEANT.
A SHELL POPE ALZHEIMER'S
SERVICES OF THE EAST BAY. I AM
HERE TODAY BECAUSE I REALLY.
WANTED TO COME UP AND REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE I'M FROM THE ADULT
DAY HEALTHCARE SEA BASS OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED SO MANY CUTS. THAT
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SERVE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE WHEN I JOINED THE ADULT
DAY HEALTHCARE MODEL TWENTY
YEARS AGO. AND OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE HAVE FOUND THAT OUR
EXPENSES HAVE REASON BECAUSE THE
LEVEL OF CARE THAT THESE FOLKS
OR ARE REQUIRING THE MEDICAL
CARE AND THEY EMPLOYMENT COSTS
OF HAVING. A MULTI PROFESSIONAL
STAFF TO CARE FOR THEM IN A WAY
THAT PROVIDES DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
I I REALLY HONESTLY ASK YOU TO
TAKE ACTION TODAY FOR BECAUSE
THE RIPPLE EFFECT OF THE PAST IT
WE ARE NOW LIVING IN THAT RIPPLE
EFFECT. AND THE RIPPLE EFFECT OF
THE FUTURE DEPENDS ON THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE TODAY THE CARE
FOR OUR CITIZENS AS THEY AGE IN
PLACE IN OUR COMMUNITY ADULT DAY
HEALTHCARE SEA BASS. NEEDS AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING IN ORDER FOR
US TO CARE FOR THE NUMBERS TODAY
AND THE NUMBERS IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
JUST A QUICK WAY TO THE SUCH ON
POINT CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE WERE FULL SUPPORT.
OF THE APOSTLE HERE JUST WANNA
MAKE THAT CLEAR THANK YOU.
CLAY CAMP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE AREA AGENCY ON AGING OF
SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES IN.
JUST ONE QUICK POINT THAT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME STATEWIDE PLANS IN
PROCESS AT LEAST BEING DEVELOPED
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO DEAL
WITH THE ARE. THIS RAPID
INCREASE OF THE AGING POPULATION
AND YOU KNOW I THINK ALL OF US
HERE WERE ALWAYS SO FOCUSED ON
WHAT'S IMMEDIATELY IN FRONT OF
US. THAT WE FORGET THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT NEXT YEAR
TO THREE YEARS OUT SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT THANK YOU SIR.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RAY CANSINO
MESSY รณ COMMUNITY BRIDGES HOW
WE OPERATE ELDER DAY A SEA BASS
PROGRAM IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX WE
SEEM THIRTY PERCENT OF SEA BASS
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE CLOSED
DOWN.
WE ARE THIS WE WERE THE SECOND
OF ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE TO
GO TO OUR MANAGED CARE ARM AND
ACTUALLY ASPIRIN INCREASE WE
RAISE THE THIRTY PERCENT. AND
THAT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE OUR ENDS OUR
DOCTORS OR PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE
PAID UNDER MARKET. OF THE
REALITY IS THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO ONE KEEP
THE DEMAND OF THE MANDATES OF
BASIC SERVICE.
TO REALLY KEEP UP WITH DEMAND OF
OUR CURRENT MARKET AND THREE TO
KEEP THE BASS OPEN ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE REALITY IS IS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO TALK TO OUR MANAGED CARE
PROVIDER.
AND GET SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR THREE COUNTY SAN BENITO ARM
I MEAN SORRY MONTEREY AND MERCED
AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WERE NOT.
ALL COUNTIES ALL COUNTIES DON'T
PARTNER THE SAME WAY WITH
MANAGED CARE.
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE REALITY
IS THAT YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TODAY. ARE TO ENSURE THATYOU
TRY TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE ARM
AND DO IT FOR THE STATE SET
THINKING.
NEW CHAIR MY NAME IS SIMEON GANT
AND I REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACKOUT NETWORK. AND
WE ARE HERE OF IN SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING INCREASE AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THE NUTRITION
ISSUE.
LOOKING AT THEM ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE LIVING REALLY I'M HEAVILY
AND WILL BE CALLED FOOD DESERTS
AND WITH THIS INCREASE IN
NUTRITION WE WILL BE ABLE TO.
ASSIST WITH OUR.
COMMUNITIES ARE WITH FOOD
NUTRITION AGING I'M ALSO WITH
THE ALZHEIMER'S ISSUE A WE ALSO
SUPPORT THAT SPECIFICALLY OF THE
PROPOSAL SAYS HERE THIS. A
DISPARITY DISPARITY IN
ALZHEIMER'S OUGHT TO SPORTS DISK
WHO DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WHERE PREVALENT RATES ARE
ALZHEIMER'S ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER GET DIAGNOSIS OF THE
DISEASE LACKS BEHIND THAT OF
WHITE AMERICANS AND WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE ON ONE OF THE ON
RECORD IN SUPPORT OF THAT? THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ONE I'LL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DYESS. FIRST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THE
BACKGROUND ON AGING PROGRAMS AND
THE RECENT FEDERAL REDUCTIONS.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT I WANNA GET
AN UNDERSTANDING WAS THEIR
CONTEMPLATION WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT BACK
FILLING THE FEDERAL CUTS.
AND SECOND QUESTION IS HOW DO
THE PROGRAMS IN YOUR VIEW
ALIGNED WITH OR NOT WITH THE
VISION GOALS AND. OBJECTIVES SET
FORTH IN THE STATE PLAN ON
AGING.
OF IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL CUTS
AT THIS POINT.
THE THE THE ACTUAL REALIZE CUTS
WERE IN THE TITLE FIVE IN THE ON
THE HIGH CAP PROGRAM.
FORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA. COM
WELL
IT'S A IT'S A MIXED A A MIXED
RESPONSE.
OUR FEDERAL FUNDING EQUATES TO
ABOUT FORTY ONE PERCENT OF OUR
FUNDING WE ALSO RECEIVE FUNDING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE.
AND MANAGED HEALTHCARE PLANS
THAT MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PLANS TO
HELP SUPPORT THE HIGH CAP
PROGRAM AND TO THAT EXTENT WE
ARE MORE FORTUNATE THAN SOME
OTHER STATES THAT RELY SOLELY ON
THE FEDERAL. ON HIGH CAP FUNDS
SO WE AND YOU KNOW OUR. OUR.
HOPEFULLY OPTIMISTIC BASED ON
ADVOCACY AMONG MANY
ORGANIZATIONS.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN TERMS
OF CONGRESS.
ATTA IN AND AND WHERE THE SENDS
UP BOMB YOU KNOW IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS. ARM ON THESE
PROGRAMS THEY HAVE BEEN BOTH OF
THESE PROGRAMS UNFORTUNATELY
REPEATEDLY OVER THE YEARS EITHER
A HOUSE OR THE SENATE SEEMS TO
PUT THEM UP FOR.
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS AND THEN
THE OTHER SIDE RESTORED THEM SO.
TWO ONE WEEK TEACH CONTINUE TO
KIND OF OPERATE IN THAT MODE
AND.
ADAM.
AND AND BE HELPFUL.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS REALLY
TRYING TO GET AT THE STATE PLAN
ON AGING MEANS TO UNDERSTAND.
NON. WHETHER IN YOUR VIEW WE'VE
ALIGNED OR NOT WITH THOSE STATED
OBJECTIVES.
SO OUR OWN OBJECTIVES IN TERMS
OF NUTRITION FOR THE STATE PLAN.
HAVE REALLY FOCUSED ON.
LOOKING AT AREAS WHERE WE SEE
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY WORKING
WITH THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
TO LOOK AT HOW WE WE MIGHT
BETTER INCOME THE COLLABORATE
BETTER.
IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS WE
ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF OUR OVERALL
DEMOGRAPHICS REACH A VERY HIGH
LEVEL MOST FIFTY PERCENT. OF
PARTICIPANTS IN THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT PROGRAMS ARE LOW
INCOME.
MINORITIES ARM. AT AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY OF COURSE A HIGH
PERCENTAGE.
OUR OUR WOMEN.
SO WE ARE MEETING OUR FEDERAL
TARGETS WELL BUT WE THINK
THEY'RE STILL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO WORK TOGETHER AND IDENTIFY
WAYS IN WHICH.
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH ACCESS ON FEEL
THE BAY OR HAVE EXPERIENCED
DISCRIMINATION EARLIER IN THEIR
LIFE CAN BE ENCOURAGED IN AND
ENGAGED AND.
BOTH BOTH PARTICIPATING IN THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM AND THE OTHER
SERVICES THAT THE AREA AGENCIES
PROVIDE AND I THINK THERE
CERTAINLY AREAS THE STATE YOU
KNOW BASED ON DEMOGRAPHICS.
WHERE THE AREA AGENCIES HAVE
REALLY DEVELOPED SOME UNIQUE?
TOOLS FOR DOING THAT
SUCCESSFULLY AND ARE YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO IS TO
HELP CROSS FERTILIZE. ON THOSE
STRATEGIES UGH ACROSS OUR
NETWORK.
I'M JUST GONNA PUT IN MY TWO
CENTS CONCERT FROM A MORE RURAL
AREA I'M ALWAYS GAS WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE EQUALLY SERVED
YES.
IT SOMETIMES IT'S HARDER FOR US
TO ACCESS SERVICES BECAUSE OF
NEEDING TO TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES
BUT. ANY EFFORT YOU CAN HAVE
WOULD BE GREAT.
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN.
ON THIS PENDING THE MAY
REVISION AND ARE CLOSE AT
HEARINGS AND WITH THAT WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TO.
I THINK.
I MAY NEED TO CREATE SOME SPACE
AT THE TABLE IF I CAN FOR CLAY
CAM.
AND DAVID MORE COLOR.
AND WE WILL START WITH CLAY AND
THEN GO ON TO DAVID.
GOOD AFTERNOON CLAY CAMP
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF.
THE AREA AGENCY ON AGING OF
SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES AND ALSO CALIFORNIA SO
SHE SENATE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR.
SO REGARDING THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION THERE SOME ARM
BACKGROUND AND AND REAL.
CRITICAL REASONS WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS.
I IN THE PAST DECADE STATE FUNDS
FOR AGING PROGRAMS FOR OLDER
AMERICANS ACT IN ALL THE
CALIFORNIA ZACH PROGRAMS.
HAVE DECREASED BYMORE THAN
FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT.
AND IN THAT SAME TIME WE'VE SEEN
THE POPULATION INCREASED BY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT INFLATION
GOES OUT SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE
INCREASED NEED AND DECREASE
RESOURCES WHICH KIND OF CREATES.
AN IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION AND I
THINK.
AND THAT'S KIND OF SHOWN BY
CURRENTLY THERE'S ALMOST ONE
POINT THREE MILLION
NUTRITIONALLY AT RISK SENIORS IN
THE STATE. PEOPLE AT THE THREAT
OF GOING HUNGRY TODAY. TOMORROW
OR DAY AFTER TOMORROW.
THE SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS
ARE GREAT AT SERVING THOSE
PEOPLE HOWEVER WERE ONLY SERVING
ABOUT A QUARTER OF A MILLION
RIGHT NOW.
SO THERE'S A MILLION SENIORS AT
RISK
OF NOT BEING SERVED.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY CRISIS.
ARM FLAT FUNDING ALSO WAS IT IS
AN ISSUE THAT CONTINUES TO
DAMAGE THE PROGRAM EACH YEAR THE
COST OF THE MEAL GOES UP ABOUT A
QUARTER PER YEAR. WHICH ISN'T A
WHOLE LOT IT'S MORE THAT IT'S
LESS THAN INFLATION BUT IT'S
REALITY THAT THE PROGRAM SPACE.
SO IF WERE FLAT FUNDED THAT
EQUATES TO TWELVE HUNDRED FEWER
MEALS FOUR VULNERABLE SENIOR PER
DAY IN THE STATE.
THAT'S THE COSTA PLAYS OUT
BECAUSE SO MANY MEALS ARE
CURRENTLY SYRUP.
SO WE REALLY WANT TO URGE ARM
THIS COMMITTEE TO FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET ON INTUITION.
I'M WE'VE HAD.
GREAT SUCCESS IN KEEPING THOSE
COSTS LOW THERE'S THOUSANDS OF
VOLUNTEERS THE DELIVER THE
SERVICES OF PROBABLY NO PROGRAM
IN THE STATE THAT USES THE MANY
VOLUNTEERS THIS BUT. I'M YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT ALL THE AGING
PROGRAMS I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYTHING MORE BASIC MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND MORE CRITICAL
THAN ACTUALLY SERVING SOMEBODY.
A NUTRITIOUS MEAL EVERY DAY. AND
IT HAS A HUGE AMOUNT OF COST
SAVINGS IN TERMS OF AVOIDING
OTHER MORE EXPENSIVE
INTERVENTIONS HEALTHCARE
EMERGENCY USE WORTH. USE ARM
CRITICAL DISEASES ALL THOSE GO
OP WHEN SOMEBODY'S NUTRITIONALLY
AT RISK HER ARE NUTRITIONALLY
SUFFERING.
SO WE KNOW THERE'S A COST
BENEFIT OF THIS.
ARM IT'S HARD TO GET THE EXACT
NUMBERS BUT IT'S SOMETHING WILL
BE MEETING WITH A A CF WITH THE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE BENEFITS AND
CRUNCHING NUMBERS SO WE CAN TELL
YOU YOU KNOW HOW MUCH OF THIS
YOU PAY FOR AND HOW MUCH YOU
SAVE AS A RESULT OF IT.
ON THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN GREAT
IN RECENT YEARS I THINK EVERY
YEAR THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDED AUGMENTED FUNDING
FOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
HOWEVER WIN THE ISSUE GOES TO
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE OR GOES TO
DISCUSSION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WERE WALKING AWAY WITH NO
DOLLARS.
SO WE'RE REALLY ASKING YOU GUYS
NOT TO TAKE NO FOR AN ANSWER
THIS YEAR WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL
ALL THE PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO
SHRINK AND SUFFER.
AND YOU KNOW IF NOT NOW WHEN TO
SOMETHING HAPPEN THE GROWTH IS
ALMOST EXPONENTIAL OF THE OLDER
POPULATION AND THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER DECADE. SO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE A
LESSENING OF DEMAND.
AND I THINK THIS KIND OF A
CHOICE HERE.
IF WE DON'T PROVIDE THESE.
PREVENTIVE KEEPING PEOPLE
INDEPENDENT TYPE PROGRAMS WE END
UP WITH MORE EXTENSIVE COST DOWN
THE LINE.
SO YOU KNOW LIKE IT OR NOT.
GROWTH IN THE SENIOR POPULATION
IS GOING TO IMPACT THE BUDGET IN
A NEGATIVE WAY. AND I THINK WE
CAN BE PROACTIVE ABOUT IT AND
DECREASE SOME OF THOSE COSTS
AND PROVIDE A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE OR WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT THE CURRENT TREND IS WHICH
IS NOTHING. AND HOPE THAT HOPE
FOR THE BEST AND AND REALLY
FINANCIALLY THE ONLY WAY THAT'S
GOING TO BE SAVINGS THERE IS IF.
A WHOLE LOT OF SENIOR START
DYING AT A MUCH FASTER RATE THAN
RIGHT NOW AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WANTS THAT
SO I'M I'M JUST URGING TO.
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THIS BUDGET
REQUEST AND HOPEFULLY SUPPORTED
AND SUPPORTIVE TO THE WALL IF
YOU CAN.
THANK YOU SIR DAVID MARKUPS.
IT HAPPENED GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVID MORE A TOWER OF
I'M A MEMBER OF THE MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE CHAIR OF THE SENIOR
NUTRITION NETWORK FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SERVE LOCALLY HERE AS THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE MEALS
ON WHEELS OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
A WE STARTED OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION A EIGHT YEARS AGO.
WHEN THE PREVIOUS PROVIDER I
HAD TO CLOSE ITS DOORS AND WE
THOUGHT WE COULD DO AS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. A LITTLE
BETTER LIVE IT CHEAPER AND BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR SENIOR CITIZENS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
TOUGH TIME MEALS ON WHEELS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE FACING NOT
JUST HERE BUT ACROSS THE STATE.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF VOLUNTEERS
A. GRADIENT WILLING TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES BUT IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO DO THEIR
SERVICE IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
MEAL TO TAKE TO THEIR. A
PERSON'S HOME.
FOR THE PAST YEAR A EIGHT YEARS
WE'VE DONE MUCH MORE WITH MUCH
LESS.
A TIME TO GAIDEN.
EVEN TOUGHER AS WE TRIED THIS
OUT SERVE THE GROWING NUMBER OF
SENIOR CITIZENS.
IN NEED OF HOME DELIVERED MEALS.
AS AND AND AT THE SAME TIME AS
WHEN FOOD AND PROGRAM COSTS
RISE.
A WE NOW HAVE THE POTENTIAL OF
SERVING LESS SENIOR CITIZENS.
AND LESS MEALS
AND STARTING A WAIT LIST.
NOTHING.
WITH.
THAT WE WANT TO DO.
NOR DO OUR HOME ONE ARE
HOMEBOUND SENIOR CITIZENS WANT
TO HEAR US.
SAY.
OUR AS MANY AS THREE HUNDRED
SENIOR CITIZENS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALONE MAY NEED
BE DROPPED A FROM OUR PROGRAM.
IN NEXT YEAR ALONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE WOULD DO
WHAT OUR VOLUNTEER THE DO.
OR WHERE ARE SENIOR CITIZENS
WILL GO FROM THERE.
WE'RE HERE TO THIS.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
SUPPORTING SENIOR TRICIA
PROGRAMS HERE AT LOCALLY AS FAR
AS WELL AS IN YOUR OWN HOMETOWN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
DOCTOR CONLEY.
ANY COMMENTS DIRECTOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ON THIS.
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
THE PROPOSAL BUT I WOULD JUST
ADD KIND OF IN TERMS OF
BACKGROUND IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND THERE WAS A NOT A
TWO MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
TO THE HOME DELIVERED MEALS
PROGRAM. AND THERE WAS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT.
GAVE THE DEPARTMENT.
AUTHORITY AND AND DIRECTION TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE FUNDS WERE
BEING USED TO ADD SERVICES AND
NOT AUGMENT.
YOU KNOW THAT SERVICES COULDN'T
BE TRANSFERRED INTO OTHER AREAS
OF FEDERAL ARE FEDERAL GRANT
ALLOWS THE AREA AGENCIES TO
TRANSFER FUNDS.
A PORTION OF TRANSIT OF OF.
NUTRITION FUNDS INTO SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES SO THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE LANGUAGE GAVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE FUNDS WERE REALLY BEING
USED COMPLETELY. TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE FROM THE DIET NUTRITION
SERVICES THAT WERE BEING
PROVIDED SUCH AS PRIVATE AS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY. I'M VERY WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT ALONG
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND.
FILIA THANK YOU.
TO BERMAN FINANCIALLY ONLY
COMES.
A YES OF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT TAKING A POSITION ON ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT OUR
PRIORITIES ARE LAID OUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDE TO PURSUE ANY
OF THESE PROPOSALS WE'D BE HAPPY
TO DISCUSS THEM FURTHER. AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
THE STATEMENT APPLIES TO ALL THE
PROPOSAL'S WE'LL HEAR.
TODAY'S HEARING.
BEFORE WE TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTATORS FEEL I'M INCLINED
TO HAVE MENTIONED THAT WE IN THE
ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR PUT THIS INTO
OUR SIDE OF THE BUDGET AND SO.
I'M HELP WITH THAT FORESHADOWS
WHERE OUR HEARTS AND MINDS ARE.
WITH THAT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TO.
PLURAL MILDRED REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
WE REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS.
CONSUMERS ADVOCATES PROVIDERS
LABOR HEALTH INSURERS AND WE TRY
TO BE THE BIG TENT REPRESENTING
OF SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE SUPPORTED THEM AUGMENTATION
FOR THE SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM
FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE APPRECIATE
AND THE ASSEMBLIES SUPPORT ON
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT CALL.
I'VE WORKED IN THIS PROGRAM AS A
SOCIAL WORKER I'M.
DEEPLY AWARE OF ITS ABILITY TO
BE A SAFETY NET PROGRAM AND
ALERT THE SYSTEMS TO VERY
VULNERABLE SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUGMENTATION
IN ORDER TO HAVE PARTICIPATED
PAYS YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO LIVE
INSIDE OF THE COMMUNITY. AND.
FOOD AUGMENTATION ALLOWS THAT
TO TAKE PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ONCE AGAIN. MY
NAME IS MARISSA MELLOW AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MEALS
ON WHEELSOF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION.
FIVE MEALS ON WHEELS PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY SERVE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED DISABLED. HOMEBOUND
SENIORS
INTRUSION SERVICES NOT
NUTRITIOUS MEALS ARE DELIVERED
AND CRITICAL BONUS CHECKS ARE.
DELIVERED DAILY BY HUNDREDS OF
VOLUNTEERS OVER FORTY THOUSAND
SENIORS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY ARE
CURRENTLY FOOD INSECURE.
AND STRUGGLE WITH.
THIS AND THIS PROBLEM WILL ONLY
WORSEN AS THE YEARS A GO ON.
THE COST FOR ONE YEAR OF
NUTRITIOUS MEALS IS EQUIVALENT
TO ONE DAY.
IN A HOSPITAL ON AVERAGE.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS YOU POSSESS
THE POWER AS WELL AS THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
KAREN FUND SERVICES FOR THE
AGING POPULATION.
MEALS ON WHEELS OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY RESPECTS RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCREASE FUNDING TO FOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS TO SEVENTEEN
MILLION THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
RAY CANSINO CEO COMMITTEE
BRIDGES ARM THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT ACTRESS COUNTY.
OPERATING MEALS ON WHEELS A
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
ONE OF OUR PROGRAMS SO I'M HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU.
OUR A MODEST PROPOSAL THAT SEEKS
TO HELP ADDRESS THE EVER GROWING
NEEDS OF SENIORS AND OUR STATE
THAT ARE SUFFERING FROM THE
BASIC ACCESS TO OUR FOOD IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
MASLOW HIERARCHY OF NEEDS WITH
CLEAR AND IDENTIFYING FOOD
ACCESS AND SHELTER THE PRIMARY
MOTIVATION AND NEEDS IN HUMANS.
BUTTE ACCESS ARE INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH TRANSLATES ITSELF INTO
MANY STUDIES LINKING TO THE ARE
A FAX OF FOOD IN THE LIKELIHOOD
OF SENIOR DEPENDENCE.
THAT'S WHY IT IS SO TROUBLING TO
FIND RECENT REPORTS SUCH AS THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN UCLA HEALTH AND
POLICY RESEARCH THAT FINDS ONE
IN FIVE SENIORS IN OUR STATE
CANNOT AFFORD BASIC NEEDS. AND
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND ROUGHLY
ONE IN SEVEN SENIORS ARE LIVING
IN EXTREME POVERTY.
THIS IS NOT A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY THIS IS CALIFORNIA THE
SIX LARGEST ECONOMY AND WE
DESERVE TO DO BETTER.
THIS IS NO DOUBT A GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AS WE SEE
THE SENIORS BECOMING THE SECOND
LARGEST HOMELESS DEMOGRAPHIC AND
THE ONE OF THE FASTEST SINGLE
GROWING DEMOGRAPHICS.
ACROSS THE STATE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE FURTHER DEMANDS ON OUR
SYSTEMS OF CARE AND WE BEGIN TO
SEE THE BABY BOOMER GENERATION
BEGIN TO RETIRE. AS WE ALSO SEE
THE LARGEST THAT GENERATION.
ARE IN SO DOING WITHOUT A
TRADITIONAL PENSION THERE SHOULD
BE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ACCORDING TO THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
AMERICANS.
DON'T HAVE A RETIREMENT ACCOUNT
AND LESSEN SIXTEEN PERCENT OF
THEM HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN THE NEXT COMING YEARS AS
PROJECTIONS OF THE GROWING
GROWTH OF SENIORS BEGINS TO
COMPOUND THIS ISSUE. WHICH WILL
SEE THE INCREASING NUMBERS OF
THOSE WHO BUILT OUR GREATEST A
STATE.
NEEDING THE SERVICES OF FOOD
AND NUTRITION ACROSS ACROSS IT.
AS POLICY MAKERS I URGE YOU TO
ADVOCATE IN THE CHAIR THAT THIS
RECOMMENDATION AN AUGMENTATION
PROCESS PROCESS THAT PASSES.
AND YOUR COMMITTEE ARM BUT ALSO
HELP TO ADVOCATE WITH THE
GOVERNOR ABOUT THE PRIORITIES IN
THE NEED THAT THIS BILL NEEDS TO
ARM NEEDS TO ADDRESS SETTING.
GOOD MORNING QUIETLY KITANA WITH
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
REPRESENTING SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
SENIORS.
IN BEHALF OF THE OLDER ADULTS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE URGE YOU TO
END THE FLAT FINDING.
WE WANT A GOURMET RECORD THAT WE
SUPPORT.
DEPARTMENT OF THE PARCHMENT OF
AGENTS REQUEST FOR SEVENTEEN
MILLION FOR NUTRITIONAL
PROGRAMS.
A HUMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
FUNDING AUGMENTATION WE LOOK AT
THIS IS A WORK DETERRENT.
IT IS NOT AN OKAY THING FOR OUR
SENIORS TO END UP IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES FOR THE LACK
OF A HOT MEAL.
AND AND.
THE SAVE CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO
BE PAYING FOR THIS WE CAN PAY
FOR A HOT MEAL. OR WE CAN PAY
FOR MEDICARE IN OUR MEDI CAL IN
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. WE
THINK THE BETTER WAY TO GO IS TO
KEEP PEOPLE AT HOME WITH A HOT
MEAL THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT
PIGMENT.
MY NAME IS NANCY IMMERSION WITH
THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS
AND WE.
R. COSPONSORED OF THIS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR.
.
CONSIDERATION WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYBODY HOW IMPATIENT
WE CAN GET STANDING IN LONG A
LONG LINE AT THE GROCERY STORE.
THE IDEA OF A WAIT LIST TO GET A
MEAL IS JUST UNIMAGINABLE TO
MOST OF US AND WE WOULD HATE TO
SEE THAT HAPPEN TO ARE
VULNERABLE POPULATION THINK IT.
BECAME.
CAROL SEWELL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WERE ALSO
COSPONSORED THIS REQUEST.
I'D JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THE
BENEFITS.
TO THE OLDER ADULTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
BOTH CONGREGATE AND HOME
DELIVERED. UNTO INK TO HELP
ADDRESS SOCIAL ISOLATION.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT A LOT OF
RESEARCH IS COMING OUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S A HUGE FACTOR AND.
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO REMAIN
HEALTHY IF THEY HAVE.
CONTACTS WITH PEOPLE IF THEY
CAN GET TO THE CONGREGATE MEAL
SITE.
IF SOMEONE IS CHECKING ON THEM
WITH THE HOME DELIVERED MEAL. WE
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AS WAS SAID EARLIER THERE'S A
VERY LARGE PROPORTION OF THE
OLDER ADULT POPULATION THAT IS
FOOD INSECURE WE CAN'T EVEN
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THAT SIXTEEN
PERCENT OF OUR POPULATION. THIS
REQUEST MAKES A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE HOPE YOU CAN
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
DEBORAH UP WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I.
AND LOSING MY VOICE SO I'LL JUST
SAY FOR ALL THE REASONS YOU'VE
HEARD.
PORT PROPOSAL.
I CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN PEERY WITH
SENIOR SIR.
I FLOW APPEARS SPEAK FOR THREE
MINUTES BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US.
AT THE MEALS ON WHEELS IN ORANGE
COUNTY TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS GIVEN. BUT
I'M NOT HERE JUST FOR THAT AND
THIS IS A PERSONAL STORY FOR ME.
HE'S ME.
UP MY FATHER'S NAME IS ROBERT
SHEAFFER.
AND ROBERT IS A. FORMER MARINE
UNIVERSALLY ACTS
AND HE IS A KOREAN WAR VETS.
AND A VERY PROUD AND VERY
STUBBORN MAN.
AND I ADMIRE THAT IN HIM.
SO HE HAS MULTIPLE HEALTH ISSUES
AND STROKE RELATED DEMENTIA BUT
HE WAS ABLE TO REMAIN AT HOME
FOR AN EXTRA THREE YEARS.
EXCUSE ME.
UP BECAUSE OF MEALS ON WHEELS I
DID NOT LIVE CLOSE ENOUGH TO
CHECK ON HIM EVERY DAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT HE RECEIVED SOME
NUTRITION EVERYDAY. I KNOW THAT
HE WAS EATING CEREAL.
OR A COLD SANDWICH WHEN HE FELT
LIKE MAKING IT AND WAS KILLING
ME. SO I'M SORRY THAT.
WHO DO X. MARK NO OUT IT'S OKAY
I JUST OF SOMETHING SUBMIT FOR?
I'M.
I COULD NOT HAVE GIVEN HIM THAT
EXTRA THREE YEARS OF
INDEPENDENCE WITHOUT MEALS ON
WHEELS SO I BEG YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER THIS REQUEST.
ACCORDING TO A JANUARY POLL IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY JAY WOMAN
OPINION RESEARCH OR VOTERS ALL
OF US.
WANT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATORS TO SUPPORT SENIORS
XTC SEVEN PERCENT OF THOSE
VOTERS FEEL THAT CALIFORNIA IS
NOT PREPARED TO CARE FOR ITS
AGING POPULATION.
EIGHTY THREE PERCENT WOULD BE
MORE LIKELY TO SUPPORT
CANDIDATES WHO HAVE A VISION.
FOR LONG TERM INVESTMENT PLAN TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASING DEMAND
FOR SENIOR SERVICES CALIFORNIA'S
AGING POPULATION.
THIS WAS MY FATHER STORY BUT
REALLY IT'S ALL OF OUR STORY
BECAUSE.
WE HAVE PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
THAT ARE GOING TO NEED THIS KIND
OF SERVICE AND STATISTICS SHOW.
THAT THERE'S A PERCENTAGE OF US
IN THIS ROOM THAT ARE GOING TO
NEED THE SERVICES
SO I'M REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
DOING. WE ARE ASKING YOU ARE
STATE OFFICIALS TO APPROVE THE
REQUEST FOR THE SEVENTEEN
MILLION INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
THESE ADDED DOLLARS WOULD
PURCHASE.
AN EXTRA TWO MILLION MEALS PER
YEAR AND SORROW SERVE OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
OLDER CALIFORNIANS.
SIGN MENSCHEN YOU AS A VOTER AND
A BABY BOOMER.
PLEASE SUPPORT I REQUEST
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE'RE
ALSO IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION ARE STATES
BEHAVIORAL RISK FACTOR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM SURVEY
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT ONE IN
FOUR CALIFORNIANS WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE LIVES ALONE.
THIS IS.
ESSENTIAL TO THEIR WELL BEING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HUNDRED CONTRACTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
AFFECTS A PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER POWELL
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
DIGNITY HEALTH CONNECTED LIVING
WE SERVE SHASTA SISKIYOU TO
HAMMER TRINITY LASSEN AND MODOC
COUNTIES. WITH OF ALL THE
PROGRAMS LISTED HERE TODAY WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE OMBUDSMAN
SO I WILL BE BACK LATER. BUT IN
TERMS OF NUTRITION HARD
CONGREGATE AND OUR HOME
DELIVERED MEALS THE FUNDING
WE'VE RECEIVED THROUGH THE CDA
THROUGH PSA TO.
ONLY COVERS ROTH FOOD COSTS.
DOESN'T COVER STAFF DOESN'T
COVER RENT
VEHICLES TO DELIVER THE MEALS
NOR GAS WE HAVE TO FUNDRAISE FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
DURING THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THE GAME
ME TOO BUT I ALSO WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT A FEW YEARS
AGO WE DID HAVE TO GO ON TO WAIT
THIS I AM ASSIST DECLINES ARE
GOING ON WAIT LISTS. AND WHAT
HAPPENED IS THAN IN MISSISSIPPI
HAD TO PICK UP THE TIME AND WE
HAVE VERY LIMITED FUNDING ALSO
SO IT DOES ROLL DOWN HILL WHEN
IT IS AVAILABLE. SO PLEASE KEEP
THEM I THINK YOU ACUMEN.
HELLO I'M JOHN POLLUTES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
PROJECTS CENTER AND WE WORK WITH
HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES EVERY MONTH
IN SANTA CRUZ MONTEREY AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES. OR IN POVERTY
THE THE SENIORS AND.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
TAKE OFF THE TABLE CHOICE THE
PEOPLE WE WORK EVERY DAY HAVE TO
MAKE ON WHAT PAY RENT.
UTILITIES.
FOOD MEDICINE.
WITH A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY WE
CAN AT LEAST TAKE FOOD OUT OF
THE EQUATION THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO AT NIGHT
RIGIDITY THAT THANK YOU.
TO A POINTER CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE THE CSL IS IN THE.
SUPPORT THIS AUGMENTATION WE
BELIEVE NO SENIOR.
SHOULD GO HUNGRY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON.
TO ALL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
JUST ONE COMMENT I THINK IT AND
ADDRESS THE.
THE FACT THAT OF PEOPLE FEEL
BETTER WHEN SOMEBODY VISITS
THEM.
I KNOW THAT THAT THEY SHOULD
THAT'S A STATISTIC THAT SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN YOUR REPORT
BECAUSE WHEN SOME BASED SAY
HELLO. I'M A JUST BRIGHTENS OUR
DAY AND I THINK AW. IT ALSO CUTS
DOWN ON SICKNESSES FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND OF YOU CAN INCLUDE
THAT IN YOUR STATISTICS I'D
REALLY APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THE FACT.
THANK YOU.
WE CAN GET THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I.
THAT IT WAS A MOMENT THAT
SPARKED ME AS WELL DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT ABOUT SOCIALIZE ICED
ISOLATION.
THERE'S A STUDY THAT CAME OUT
THIS PAST YEAR THAT SAID LET
LONELINESS WAS A WORSE RISK
FACTOR THAN OBESITY. AND IT
APPLIES TO EVERYONE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE ADVOCATES WHO ARE HERE
YOU SAID IN YOUR STATEMENT BUT I
WANT YOU TO EXPLICITLY ANSWER IF
YOU CAN.
WHAT IS THE EFFECT OF NO FUNDING
INCREASE
AND HOW MUCH OF THE SEVENTEEN
MILLION IS NECESSARY JUST TO
KEEP YOUR CURRENT SERVICE
LEVELS?
FLAT FUNDING WOULD RESULT IN
TWELVE HUNDRED ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED MEALS LAS PER DAY OVER
YEAR THAT'S ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND I'M ROUNDING
OFF A FEW THOUSAND BUT. YOU KNOW
GENERALLY THAT'S THE IMPACT OF
IT.
I'M THAT'S TAKEN AN AVERAGE OF
BOTH.
CONGREGATE DINING CENTERS
BECAUSE CONGREGATE DINING CENTER
IS A VERY IMPORTANT HOME
DELIVERED MEALS.
SO IF.
I'M I'M FORGETTING WHAT THE
OTHER PART OF THE QUESTION WAS
THAT THEY HAVEN'T CAN MILLION
HOW MUCH OF THAT OUT HOW MUCH
THEY'RE A TAPE TO KEEP CURRENTS
RIGHT LET'S SO IT WOULD TAKE
ABOUT FOUR MILLION TO KEEP
SERVICES FLAT.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT HOW DOES
THIS PROPOSAL ONLINE OR NOT WITH
THE STATE PLAN AND. I'M GONNA
REFERENCE IT VERY GOOD READING
BUT HAD ON AND. ON PAGE THIRTY
TWO YOU HAVE OBJECTIVE THREE BE
WHAT SAYS TO SUPPORT OLDER
ADULTS AND INCREASING THEIR
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS FOODS. AND
ESTABLISH HEALTHY EATING HABITS
RIGHT A RIGHT IF I MENTION
THOUGH THAT THE STATE PLAN.
ANTICIPATES NO INCREASES IN
FUNDING IT IT CERTAINLY HAS A
HIGH LEVEL GOAL FOR THE
APARTMENT OBVIOUSLY IN OUR
ADVOCACY ROLE.
BUT IN BUT WE ANTICIPATE THE
FUNDING THAT WE.
THAT WE HAVE AT AT THE AT WITHIN
THIS FOUR YEAR TIME PERIOD.
ON.
WITH THAT I THINK WE
FORESHADOWED.
WHERE THE COMMITTEE WILL FILL
LATER BUT FOR THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE?
LIKE TO INVITE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GOMEZ REYES.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY
DIFFER IF YOU'D LIKE TO LEASE A
COMENTAR KAREN JONES TO GO FIRST
OR IF YOU WANT TO START HOWEVER
YOU'D LIKE SOME.
I THINK HAVING THEM GO FIRST AS
WE HAVE THEM LISTED WITH THE
PERFECT THANK YOU.
THE TERM.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION KAREN JONES IS
STUCK IN RAIN AND I'M EXPECTING
HER TO WALK IN THE DOOR ANY
MINUTE. BUT BECAUSE OMBUDSMAN'S
ARE MENGES MAY DO ANYTHING AT
ANY POINT I'VE TASK ARE FRESNO
MADERA OMBUDSMAN TO COME UP AND
TESTIFY.
A SELF
BUT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN.
SO. THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LISA COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALCUTTA.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE INVESTED IN THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AND THOSE
PROGRAMS DID WHAT YOU ASKED OF
THEM.
BUT THE GAINS IN PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES PETE BY MID TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
LAST FALL FORTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
OUR PROGRAMS.
ENTERED FACILITIES IN RESPONSE
TO A COMPLAINT RATHER THAN AND
ANNOUNCE FACILITY VISIT.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THEY WERE NO
LONGER OPERATING FROM A PLACE OF
PREVENTION THEY WERE SIMPLY
RESPONDING TO ONE COMPLAINT
AFTER ANOTHER? NEVER GETTING A
HANDLE ON THE CORE ISSUES AT
BEST ADDRESSING THE SYMPTOMS AND
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT CRACK FOR
HELP.
OVER THE YEARS THIS COMMITTEE
HAS ASKED US TO LOOK AT FUNDING
OUTSIDE OF GENERAL FUNDS.
AND.
TO HAVE SINCERELY TRIED.
BUT AS EVIDENCED BY THE RECENT
DISCLOSURE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THAT WE WILL BE
LOSING TWELVE PERCENT FUNDING.
AUGMENTATION DERIVED FROM A
SPECIAL FUND.
AND WITH THE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE LOST FROM OUR
FEDERAL FUNDS.
I JUST SETTLE LOSSES TO WHERE TO
LOOK AT NOT GENERAL FUNDS.
I'VE HEARD IN ITEM I HEARD IN
OTHER HEARINGS THAT A DEFENSE
FOR NOT FULLY FUNDING THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS THAT THE
STATE ALREADY FUNDS LICENSING
AGENCIES.
BUT THE EFFORTS OF THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS ARE NOT A DUPLICATION
OF SERVICES BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
WHAT THESE FOLKS ARE RESPONDING
TO ARE NOT FACILITY REGULATORY
VIOLATIONS OR CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS.
AT LEAST THEY DON'T START OUT
THAT WAY.
BUT WITHOUT EARLY INTERVENTION
THOSE PROBLEMS WILL AND DO GROW.
THEY BECOME COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING FOR THE STATE.
FOR THOSE VERY LICENSING
AGENCIES.
AND AND HOW IS ONE TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE RESIDENTS.
THE NEEDLESS SUFFERING THAT THE
RESIDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR LICENSING TO
GET INVOLVED BECAUSE THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS SO UNDER
FUNDED.
SO ARE FUNDING REQUEST THIS
YEAR.
WE REALLY LOOK AT WHAT THE
PROGRAMS NEED AND WE IDENTIFIED
THE FOUR AREAS.
SO THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ITS EYES AND EARS WE'VE
JUST GOT TO GET PEOPLE BACK IN
OUR FACILITIES. AND WHEN THOSE
PEOPLE ARE IN THE WIND ARE
OMBUDSMAN'S ARE IN THE
FACILITIES THE LOCAL PROGRAMS
HAVE ALREADY STARTED THE PROCESS
OF IDENTIFYING THEIR MORE
PROBLEMATIC FACILITY SO THEY CAN
SPEND EVEN EXTRA EFFORTS.
TO RAISE UP THE STANDARDS IN
THOSE PROBLEMATIC FACILITIES.
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SEED MONEY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT VOLUNTEERISM HAS
DROPPED TO A DRAMATIC LEVEL IN
OUR LOCAL PROGRAMS.
AND AND WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE STATE
OMBUDSMAN WILL BE DOING A
TRAINING THIS SPRING FOR THE
LOCAL PROGRAMS. ON HOW TO DO
INNOVATIVE OUGHT RECRUITMENT AND
RETAINING OF VOLUNTEERS.
BUT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU. ALL
THE TRAINEES IN THE WORLD DO NOT
PAY FOR ADS IN THE LOCAL
NEWSPAPER THEY DO NOT PAY FOR
PRINTING COSTS FOR FLYERS THEY
DO NOT PAY FOR THE STAFF TIME TO
GET OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THE VOLUNTEER
OPPORTUNITY.
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME SEED
MONEY TO UTILIZE THIS THIS
TRAINING.
THE THIRD AREA IS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL COMPLAIN
INVESTIGATIONS WHAT HAPPENS IS
YOU'RE IN THE FACILITIES MORE
OFTEN YOU'RE UNCOVERING MORE
ISSUES. BUT THIS IS A BELL CURVE
IT GETS THE POINT WHERE THE
FACILITY WITH A COMPLETE START
TO DECREASE BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
THE FACILITY OFTEN ENOUGH THAT
YOU ARE CHANGING THE CULTURE.
AND YOUR YOUR IMPROVING IT AS AN
ONGOING MEASURE.
AND THE FINAL PART OF OUR ASK IS
A TWO POINT THREE MILLION
REPLACING.
LOCAL PROGRAMS ARE SIMPLY USING
SERVICE DOLLARS TO COVER
OPERATING EXPENSES.
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY IT BEFORE.
PREVENTION THROUGH OMBUDSMAN
ADVOCACY SAVE THE STATE MONEY.
THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND INEXPENSIVE
TOOL THE STATE HAS FOR
FULFILLING THE MANDATED
PROMISES.
WE'RE COMING BACK ASKING YOU FOR
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY THERE IS NO
FLUFF IN THIS ASK.
FOR THE LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
WHAT THEY DO BEST.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THIS
TIME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON
GOING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LISA.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
A LOCAL NINJA.
I DON'T WANT THAT.
THE BOTH. WELL I THINK YOU
NEVER.
WORKING WITH A BRAND
NOT GRANTING THE INNER BUT
STILL.
THIS JUST SPEAKS TO THAT GET IT
DONE.
WELL THINK IT AND MY NAME IS
SUSAN BUSAN AND I'M THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR FRESNO MADERA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM I'VE
BEEN THERE FOR. WILL BE TWO
YEARS IN JUNE.
AND SO. WE'VE HAD A GREAT RIDE
IT'S BEEN VERY. REWARDING WITH A
LOT OF WONDERFUL CHANGING MY
BASS FINDING.
IS TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHICH CONSISTS OF COURSE OF
STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL I. A
THREE FULL TIME A NUMBERS MAN AT
ONE TWENTY HOUR AND TO TEN HOURS
TOTALING FOUR FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT.
TO IN THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS NOT ENOUGH TO RUN THE
PROGRAM.
IT JUST IS NOT WITH PAY AND
STAFF AND RENT AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT GO ALONG WITH BUT
THAT ASIDE. OUR CONTEXT BUT
SUPPLIES EVERY CONTACT ZIP ABOUT
OUR CONTRACT IS A BUT AS WE HAVE
TO DO VISIT A MONTH TO EACH OF
OUR FACILITIES. AB TWO HUNDRED
AND.
THIRTY TWO FACILITIES RIGHT NOW
WITH TWELVE PENDING RIGHT NOW
FOR LICENSING. NEARLY EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED BEDS WHICH WE HAVE
AB ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES WHAT'S
ABOUT A RESIDENT PRESCRIBE. KIND
HOW WE'VE BREAKDOWN IN FRESNO
MADERA.
.
THE BEST PART ABOUT MY PROGRAM
IN MOUNT MY VOLUNTEERS.
I LOVE MY VOLUNTEERS IF THEY DO
THIS VERY VERY DIFFICULT WORK.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE WHY THEY
WANT TO BUT THEY DO AND I LOVE
THEM FOR THAT. I STARTED ON JUNE
SIX OF SIXTEEN I HAD SEVENTEEN
VOLUNTEERS.
TO COVER ALL THE FACILITIES AND
I HAVE THIRTY ONE I'VE GOT THREE
ON LEAVES I HAVE THIRTY FOUR.
.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
TO TO DO THE KIND OF WORK THAT
WE WANT TO DO TO REALLY
INVESTIGATE AND TAKE CARE OF THE
CLAIM TO THE COMPLAINTS ON THE
PROBLEMS AND THE ISSUES THAT
COME UP.
WHILE WE CAN REIMBURSE THEM FOR
THE MILEAGE AND THAT'S IT AND
WILLIAM PENN STATE RATE BUT
THEY'RE VERY UNDERSTANDING. A
LOT OF MY VOLUNTEERS DONATE
THEIR MILEAGE AND THAT'S BEEN
GREAT OF THAT'S GOT FROM TWO
PEOPLE DOING IT TO ABOUT TWELVE
OR FOURTEEN THAT DO EVERY MONTH
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN OUR WORK.
OF WHICH SAYS A LOT ABOUT THEIR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THIS
PROGRAM.
LAUGHS AT THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
ARE I'M IT'S BEEN CONTRIBUTED
FIVE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO HOURS OF TIME.
THAT'S WHAT THEY RIGHT DOWN THE
LOT OF RESEARCH TIME AND PAPER
WRITING THEIR REPORT WRITING
TIME THEY DON'T LIE AGAIN BUT
THIS IS IN THE FACILITIES THEY
RE THEY THEY.
HAD THAT MUCH TIME TALENT AND
EFFORT TO HELP IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA YOU MULTIPLY THAT
TIMES ARE REALLY ALL HAVE AS
LAST YEAR'S RATE THEM CHANGE THE
NEW ONE YET THAT'S.
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED THREE DOLLARS.
BUT THE VALUE.
THAT'S A LOT I'M LOT OF DOLLAR
VALUE ON TOP OF THE REAL VALUE
OF WHAT THE GET THE REAL VALUE
IS AND WHAT THEY DO IN THE LIFE
TO EQUIPMENT ADVOCATE FOR. A
WONDERFUL RESIDENTS AT THAT WE
SEE A REGULAR BASIS OUR
OMBUDSMAN STAFF NUMBERS AND
PROVIDED SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
HOURS OF INTAKE CASE
INVESTIGATION AND COMPLAINED VIA
FOLLOW UP BUT THE BEST PART OF
WHAT THEY DO IS TO BUILD A
PROVIDE. TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
OUR FIELD OMBUDSMAN OVERALL IN
THEATERS IT'S CRUCIAL TO HAVE
SOMEBODY IN THE OFFICE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
.
THE THING ABOUT THE ON BUTTON
PROGRAMMING YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THIS BUT.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE DOING WHAT
WE DO.
WE THERE'S NO DUPLICATION OF
SERVICES NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO DO
IT.
BUT WE'RE EQUIPPED TO DO IT
AND THAT'S UNUSUAL BECAUSE I YOU
KNOW I WORK IN THE NONPROFIT
WILL FOR QUITE AWHILE IS ALWAYS
SOMEBODY WHO SERVES A
POPULATION.
FROM THIS ANGLE FROM THAT ANGLE
FROM HERE THEY ALL HAVE A
DIFFERENT FOCUS.
WE HAVE ONE FOCUS THAT'S
RESIDENT RIDE THREADS EGGMAN OF
ITS ADVOCACY TEACH THEM TO FIND
THEIR VOICE HELPING THEM.
AND NOBODY ELSE DOES IT AND WE
DON'T DO IT WHAT WILL HAPPEN AND
THAT'S THE SCARY PART BECAUSE
AS%
YOU SEEN THE NUMBER OF
VOLUNTEERS DECLINE.
AS THE PROGRAM COORDINATOR LOTS
OF STUFF TO KEEP ME AWAKE AT
NIGHT.
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE A WHO'S WHO DO
THE WORK AND WHO'S GOING TO GO
OUT THERE FOLLOW UP ON THE
COMPLACENT ENOUGH TIME.
SO BIG A BIG PART OF WHAT LISA
SHARE WITH LIZA FAIR REVIEW WAS
THAT RE BASING WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO OUR PROGRAM IT
WOULD ALLOW ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS
TO HIRE. A PROGRAM COORDINATOR
PROGRAMS ARE A.
WHO DON'T HAVE A PROGRAM GOING
IN A VOLUNTEER COORDINATOR
VOLUNTEER MANAGER SOMEONE WHO
COULD BE IN? IT TAKE THE ROLE
AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RECRUITING.
AND RETAINING AND EQUIPPING AND
LOVING ON VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT.
IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME IF YOU
DON'T DO IT WELL IT TAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME AND I
DO IT BUT I STILL HAVE TO DO MY
REGULAR JOB.
AND THAT WOULD MAKE MY LIFE
EASIER TO MAKE ALL OF OUR LIVES
EASIER BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE A
GO TO PERSON WHO WILL ALWAYS BE
THERE FOR THEM TO GIVE THEM THE
TOOLS THEY NEED. THAT MIGHT NEED
US FOR THE PROGRAM TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
BUT THAT'S THAT WOULD JUST BE
THEIR CHEERLEADER AND THEIR
TRAINER WHATEVER IT IS THEY THEY
NEED FROM THAT PERSON THAT'S
WHAT WE COULD BE ABLE TO DO IF
WE HAD. AN INCREASE IN OUR BASE
FUNDING.
.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT EVERY
INDUSTRY CHANGES EVERY YEAR EVEN
THE SMALLEST OF NON PROFITS GETS
A THREE PERCENT COST OF LIVING
RAISE WHAT WE CAN TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS WITH THE SAME BASE
FUNDING.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE AND IT'S
UNHELPFUL
SO WE'RE HOPING FOR A LITTLE
HELP HERE AND SO BASICALLY.
THE LACK OF THE SPACE FUNDING
INCREASE FOR THE LAST TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AS.
IT COMES UP IN SO MANY WAYS LIKE
I AM ARE YOU RIGHT NOW EIGHTEEN
PERCENT OVER IN MY MILEAGE.
ALLOTMENT IN MY BUDGET FOR THIS
YEAR AS OF FEBRUARY AND A FOR A
BOY.
HOW MANY OF THE PAY MY OMBUDSMAN
FOR THEIR LOUSY FIFTY CENTS A
MILE OF LIKING GIVE THEM?
THOSE OF THE CONCERNS.
BECAUSE I WILL HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING IN MY IN MY JUST IN MY
BASS LINE.
THAT OTHER THING IT'S GONNA
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT IN THIS WAS
BROUGHT UP AT MY LESS KCB
MEETING WE HAVE ONE EVERY MONTH
WITH ALL MY VOLUNTEERS AND ONE
OF THEM SAID YOU KNOW THE NEW
TAX CUTS HAVE OF IT'S TAKING
AWAY THE DEDUCTION FOR DONATING
MILEAGE.
AND SEVERAL OF THEM SAID YOU
KNOW I'M I'M PROBABLY GONNA HAVE
TO START SUBMITTING FOR MILEAGE.
AFTER THE KILL ME.
IT'S GOING TO KILL ME AND MY
BUDGET AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO BECAUSE I NEED MORE
VOLUNTEERS IT'S CATCH TWENTY
TWO.
BECAUSE I NEED THE PEOPLE I'LL
PAY MILEAGE.
I DON'T HAVE THE MONEY BUT I
NEED THE PEOPLE IF YOU BRING
THEM ONBOARD YOU CREATE MORE
MILEAGE AND SO IT'S JUST THIS
VICIOUS CIRCLE IT WILL HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON MY BUDGET
EXPERIENCE TO BE ON THE CITY I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO FIX I DON'T
HAVE A. A PLAN FOR BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
.
A BIG PART OF OF.
THE THE PROBLEM WITH THE FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE IT WE GO THROUGH
PROGRAM COORDINATORS IN THIS
INDUSTRY LIKE CRAZY.
I REALLY HADN'T SEEN THAT HAPPEN
OF THE NEXT CLASS NEXT WEEK WE
HAVE TWELVE NEW ONES.
I MEAN SINCE LAST YEAR AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE TWELVE THE PROGRAM
COORDINATORS A THIRD OF THE
STATE.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
A HARD JOB.
AND THERE IS NO MONEY AND
THERE'S NO BUDGET HARDLY TO WORK
WAY THEN SO BE IT THERE'S ALWAYS
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK IF YOU'RE
NOT.
ABLE TO MAKE IT MOST OF US ARE
SO PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT WE DO
THAT WE STAY.
WITH YOU A SHORTER LIFE I THINK
BUT THAT.
BUT ARE OF THE NEW.
IT'S LIKE IN MY PARTICULAR CASE
I WAS THE FOURTH PROGRAM CORNER
IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
THE TAKE MY JOB.
SO AND IT HAPPENS EVERYWHERE IF
YOU IF WE HAVE A JOB WITH MORE
SECURE BASING BASE FUNDING THAT
WE CAN KEEP GOOD PEOPLE SO.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHERE AT.
WE WOULD JUST LOVE YOUR SUPPORT
TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE.
OUR BASELINE OUR BASE FUNNY RE.
BEST TERM YOU TAMI AND.
I THINK YOU WITH THE AMAZING
THING HAPPEN IF WE COULD.
GET OR VOLUNTEER.
YOU VERY MUCH
SOMEONE WILL GO THE STRATUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
I CAN'T TELL THAT YOU HAVEN'T
DONE THIS BEFORE YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB THANK YOU. AGREED.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS MY DISTRICT
IN THOSE ACROSS OUR STATE.
TO RESPECTFULLY SEEK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGETARY
INITIATIVE TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION.
IN GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR THE
LOCAL LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM.
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS MANDATED TO
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW TO PROTECT
RESIDENTS RIGHTS AND SURE
RESIDENTS ARE TREATED WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY.
THE WORK THAT LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN DO.
IS MANY TIMES OVER LOOKED.
THEY PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
LIVES OF OUR SENIORS IN LONG
TERM CARE. OMBUDSMAN OR ABLE TO
INTERVENE ON BEHALF OF RESIDENT
AND IDENTIFYING BEST A GATE AND
RESOLVE COMPLAINTS.
COMPLAINTS AT DONE IDENTIFIED BY
A BUDS MEN ARE OFTEN THE
PRECURSORS TO MORE SEVERE QUE
CASES OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
WHICH TEND TO BE MORE COSTLY.
DESPITE THE GROWING FAVORABLE
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
AND THE GROWING SERVICE NEED.
STATE FUNDING FOR THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
HAVE EXPERIENCED MINIMAL FUNDING
RESTORATION.
DURING THE MONTH MARK DURING THE
MARCH EIGHTH SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
HEARING THE PROGRAMS LEARNED
THEY WILL EXPERIENCE AS WAS
NOTED EARLIER A TWELVE PERCENT
DECREASE IN PROGRAM FUNDING
SUPPORT. DUE TO THE LOSS OF A
FOURTH YEAR OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING
AUGMENTATION.
CONSIDERING THAT REDUCTION
BENITO FOR PROGRAM FREEBASING IS
EVEN MORE CRITICAL AS THE ANNUAL
BASE OF THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH PROGRAM. HAS
NOT BEEN ADJUSTED.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AS
WAS NOTED EARLIER.
THIS NECESSARY ADJUSTMENT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
TO THE SMALL PROGRAMS THAT
STRUGGLE WITH SUSTAINABILITY.
LACK OF FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
PUTS OF RESIDENTS AND THE
QUALITY OF SERVICE IN JEOPARDY.
IN TWO THOUSANDSIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS CONDUCTED
ALMOST SEVENTY THOUSAND
ANNOUNCED VISITS TO NURSING
HOMES AND ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES.
THEY INVESTIGATED AND RESOLVED
OVER FORTY THOUSAND COMPLAINTS
INCLUDING COMPLAINTS FOR ELDER
ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
THEY PROVIDED OVER FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND CONSULTATIONS TO
RESIDENTS.
GAVE NEARLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CONSULTATIONS TO FACILITIES
AND WITNESSED OVER TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED ADVANCED
HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVES.
AND PROPERTY TRANSFER
DECLARATIONS.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF ASSISTED
LIVING BAD HAS INCREASED BY OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND THE PAST TEN
YEARS. THE NUMBER OF PAID
OMBUDSMAN IN CALIFORNIA. HAS
BEEN DECREASED BY ALMOST TWENTY
PERCENT.
THIS PROPOSAL. THAT IS BEING
SUBMITTED WOULD RESTORE AND
ENHANCE A PROGRAM PROVEN TO BE
EXCEPTIONALLY EFFECTIVE IN
COMPLAINTS RESOLUTION.
COST EFFECTIVE THROUGH ITS USE
OF VOLUNTEERS AS WAS NOTED.
AND OF EQUAL IMPORTANCE IT'S A
DEBILITY TO PREVENT OCCURRENCES
OF HARM AND SUFFERING TO
RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES.
I RISK BY UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE SO
MANY GREAT NEEDS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT WOULDN'T
MENTION JUST BEFORE US ABOUT.
FOOD FOR OUR SENIORS.
BUT TODAY I ALSO RESPECT WILL BE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
PRIORITIZE THIS FUNDING REQUEST
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN STATE
BUDGET
THANK YOU THANK HER.
FROM.
NEXT I'D LIKE TO IF I CAN JUST
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM FOR BUSINESS
SAKE AND THEN I BELIEVE WE HAVE
JOB RODRIGUEZ REYES RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE STATE LONG TERM. CARE
OMBUDSMAN.
WHO IS NEXT ON A PANEL?
ARAMBULA HERE HARPER HERE
MATHIS RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM
.
IN EUROPE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
GETTING MEMBERS JOE RODRIGUEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN.
THE AUTHORITY FOR THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM COMES TO
US FROM THE FEDERAL OLDER
AMERICANS ACT AND IT'S
STATE COMPANION THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT.
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROVIDES POLICY AND OVERSIGHT TO
THE LOCAL LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVES ARE ADVOCATES
WERE ADVOCATES FOR RESIDENTS AND
WE PROMOTE AND PROTECT RESIDENTS
RIGHTS.
THE STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ANALYZES COMMENTS ON
AND MONITORS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AN IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS REGULATIONS
AND EVER OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
POLICIES AND ACTIONS.
THAT PERTAIN TO THE HEALTH
SAFETY WELFARE AND RIGHTS OF
RESIDENTS.
STATE AND WAS AND ALSO
RECOMMENDS ANY CHANGES AND SUCH
LAWS REGULATIONS POLICIES AND
ACTIONS AS THE OFFICE DETERMINES
TO BE APPROPRIATE.
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY STATE CERTIFIED OMBUDSMEN
VOLUNTEERS AND A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY PART TIME AND FULL TIME
PAID STAFF AND LOCAL PROGRAMS.
IDENTIFY INVESTIGATE RESOLVE
COMPLAINTS AND CONCERNS ON
BEHALF OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
IN ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
INCLUDING DISTINCT PART NURSING
FACILITIES INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES AND UP ABOUT
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
LAST YEAR LOCAL OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS INVESTIGATED MORE THAN
FORTY ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS.
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN. LOCAL LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS RECEIVED A
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
THEY ALSO RECEIVED AN ADDITIONAL
FOREIGNER DEL THOUSAND FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FUND. AS A
DIRECT RESULT IN THE INCREASE IN
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY BED
FEE.
ON A YEAR TO YEAR A ONE TIME
BASIS LOCAL OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS
ALSO RECEIVED AN ADDITIONAL ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
HEALTH FACILITIES CITATION
PENALTIES ACCOUNT.
WHAT DID THIS LEAD TO?
COMPARING TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THE FOLLOWING OCCURRED.
WE'VE SEEN A TWENTY ONE PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
INFORMATION CONSULTATION
ACTIVITIES PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS.
AN ELEVEN PERCENT INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF CONSULTATIONS TO
FACILITIES.
AN EIGHTEEN PERCENT INCREASE IN
NUMBERS AND REPRESENTATIVES
PARTICIPATING IN FACILITY
SURVEYS ARE INSPECTIONS
CONDUCTED BY THE LICENSING
AGENCIE.
A TWENTY TWO PERCENT INCREASE.
IN ON WHAT WOULD WORK EDUCATING
AND EMPOWERING FAMILY COUNCILS.
A SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE IN OUR
IN WORK EDUCATING AND EMPOWERING
RESIDENT COUNCILS AND
FACILITIES.
A SIX PERCENT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF VOLUNTEER IN STAFFING
TRAINING HOURS.
AND.
WITH THIS ONE TIME.
PORT THE PROGRAM IS RECEIVED.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HIRE LIMITED
TERM PART TIME POSITIONS KNOWING
THAT FUNDING COULD AND JUNE
THIRTIETH.
THAT HAS HELP SUPPORT THE WORK
OF MAKING THOSE NON COMPLAINT
RELATED FACILITY VISITS AND ALSO
INVESTIGATION OF OF COMPLAINTS
IN AND FACILITIES.
AGAIN WITH THE ONE TIME ONLY
MONEY WHICH WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF.
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
REIMBURSEMENT TO VOLUNTEERS FOR
THEIR MILEAGE AND ADDITIONAL
TRAINING FOR OUR
REPRESENTATIVES.
OF SEVERAL OF OUR PROGRAMS ALSO.
PURCHASED A EQUIPMENT LIKE
COMPUTERS THAT THAT HAD BEEN
LONG DELAYED BECAUSE OF OF THE
LACK OF FUNDING FOR THE. FOR
THESE TYPES OF THINGS.
.
WE WERE ASKED TO TALK ABOUT THE
STATE PLAN AND THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE OF THE LONG TERM CARE BUT
SOME PROGRAM IN THE STATE PLAN.
.
WE'VE WE HAVE SEVERAL OBJECTIVES
IN OUR STATE PLAN FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MAKING SEIZING MAKING
INFORMATION AND TRAINING ON
PERSON CENTERED COUNSELING
PRINCIPLES AND PROCESS HE'S
AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS.
TRANSITION COORDINATORS AND
AGENCIES SERVING OLDER ADULTS
WITH PERSONS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND WE'VE PROVIDED SOME OF THAT
TRAINING AT OUR ON THAT'S BEEN
FALL CONFERENCE WERE PRIDING
AGAIN NEXT WEEK WHEN WE TRAIN
OUR NEW COORDINATORS. THAT WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE.
TESTIMONY TODAY. WE'RE
EXPANDING.
AS LISA. HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT IN VOLUNTEERISM TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
SERVICES TO OLDER ADULTS PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES AND FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
WE'RE. PRESENTING HOPEFULLY
PROMISING INFORMATION ON HOW.
PROGRAMS IN THIS DAY AND AGE CAN
RECRUIT AND TRAIN AND RETAIN
VOLUNTEERS.
THAT THE WORK THAT THE LOCAL
OMBUDSMAN REPRESENTATIVES
ENGAGING IS DIFFICULT WORK IT'S
NOT EASY.
THIS IS A MOVIE ISN'T A A WARM
FUZZY VOLUNTEER EXPERIENCE
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE CASES THAT
WE INVESTIGATE OR ABUSE NEGLECT
AND EXPLOITATION.
I SEE A LOT OF UGLINESS AND IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN PEOPLE TO DO THIS
IMPORTANT WORK.
THE STATE PLAN ALSO RECOGNIZES
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL TRAINING
OF OMBUDSMAN REPRESENTATIVES AND
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY BUT WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES OVER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. IN ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES
APS FORTUNATELY HAS BEEN THE
BENEFICIARY OF SOME GENEROUS
FUNDING FOR THE LEGISLATURE. TO
LOOK AT.
TRAINING FOR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES WORKERS.
APS ISM KIND ENOUGH TO SHARE
THOSE RESOURCES WITH US AND AS
SPACE ALLOWS WILL WILL ENCOURAGE
OUR LOCAL OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT TRAINING
WHICH WILL IMPROVE THEIR SKILLS
AND HAD IN HANDLING THESE MORE
SEVERE IN COMPLICATED CASES OF
ABUSE NEGLECT AND EXPLOITATION.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH APS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL ON MANDATED
REPORTER TRAINING.
THAT THAT THIS TRAINING WILL BE
CUSTOMIZED TO THE MANDATED
REPORTER BASED ON WHERE THAT
PERSON WORKS.
SO IF YOU WORK IN A HOSPITAL.
DID THE TRAINING WILL BE
APPROPRIATE FOR WEARING
COMPLAINTS OF ABUSE NEGLECT AND
EXPLOITATION GO IF YOU WORK IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY IT'LL
BE APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
POPULATION.
SO WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED THAT.
APS IS WILLING TO SHARE THOSE
RESOURCES WITH US
AND WE THINK IT WILL HELP
IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN THE
REPORTING SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WERE ALSO COLLABORATING WITH
SOCIAL SERVICES AN ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND OTHER
KEY STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
COMMISSION ON AGING.
TO COORDINATE EFFORTS TO OBSERVE
AND PUBLICIZE WORLD ELDER ABUSE
AWARENESS DAY IN JUNE.
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN WILL
CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES A NAY PS ON THIS EVENT.
AND WE COORDINATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO OBSERVE AND
PUBLICIZE WORLD ELDER ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN WILL
CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH SEE FOR
A. AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON
OBSERVING AND PUBLICIZE WORLD
ELDER ABUSE OF MONTH MONTH
ACTIVITIES.
IS IT DURING THE MONTH OF JUNE
BUT ALSO GREATER AWARENESS OF OF
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THANK YOU SIR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LEรณN
THE COMMENTS.
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD FLAG FOR
MEMBERS IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE
FIFTEEN THE OVERSIGHT ISSUE.
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
THE PROPOSED SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
AND CHANGES FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AN ONGOING RELATED TO
LANGUAGE AROUND ONE THE
INVESTMENT PROGRAM RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
STATE HEALTH. FACILITIES
CITATION ACCOUNT OPERATED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WE ALONG WITH
STAKEHOLDERS JUST RAGE SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THAT
LANGUAGE AND.
WERE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE THAT
TO THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH THEY
THEN LATER INCORPORATED AND SOME
REVISED LANGUAGE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BEING REFUSED REVIEWED
BY STAKEHOLDERS.
AND TO THE EXTENT THROUGH THAT
REVIEW PROCESS OF NO OTHER
ISSUES ARE RAISED AND THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ADOPT
THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOT TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE.
DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHICH SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRTH ELIZABETH THAT'S WHAT ELSE
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTIES OF
SANTA CRUZ AND VENTURA VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU CAN.
LARA MILDRED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT THIS
PROGRAM HOLD SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE
AND DOES IT BY REPRESENTING AND
BEING A VOICE FOR THE RESIDENT
THIS IS THE HALLMARK OF PERSON
CENTER CARE WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME TRYING TO GET THAT. AND
THIS IS A VERY EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT PROTECTS
VULNERABLE PEOPLE DEVELOPS
PERSON CENTER CARE.
I'M RACHEL TATE WITH THE WAY I
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR THE WISE
AND HEALTHY AGING LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
PROUDLY SERVING OVER SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS IN OVER EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES IN LOS ANGELES.
LAST YEAR WE INVESTIGATED OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND CASES WITH ONLY
TWENTY STAFF AND SIXTY FIVE
VOLUNTEERS.
WE ARE COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
THAT WORKS TO INTERVENE BEFORE
MINOR ISSUES BECOME
CATASTROPHIC.
OUR TOP THREE COMPLETE
CATEGORIES ARE RESIDENTS
RESIDENT PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL
ABUSE.
INAPPROPRIATE DISCHARGES AND
EVICTIONS AND GROSS NEGLECT.
DEMAND FROM ELDERS INDEPENDENT
ADULT CONSUMERS IS INCREASING
AND THE CASES ARE BECOMING MORE
AND MORE COMPLEX.
WITH THE POTENTIAL ONE MILLION
DOLLAR LOSS THE FUNDING WE WILL
BE SEEING IN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR DUE TO THE PROJECTED LACK
OF FUNDS IN THE CITATION PENALTY
ACCOUNT.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS.
ROL
COMMISSION ON AGING I JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS ALSO
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF SOCIAL
ISOLATION THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER.
IF YOU HAVE NEVER VISITED A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT MOST
FAMILIES DON'T GO.
AND IF THEY DO IT'S VERY RARE.
I GREW UP
FOLLOWING MY MOTHER TO VISIT AN
ELDERLY FRIEND AND OTHERS IN THE
NURSING HOME. THESE THIS WOMAN
AND HER.
DAUGHTER AND SON IN LAW HAD
MOVED FAR AWAY THERE WAS NO ONE
ELSE WE BECAME HER FAMILY. AND
THAT CONTINUES TO THIS DAY SO
THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO HAVE THESE
VOLUNTEERS GOING IN AND.
DEVELOPING RELATIONSHIPS AND
BEING THAT FRIEND AND THAT
VOICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME'S NICOLE HOW I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF CONTRA
COSTA AND SOLANO I REPRESENT A
TEAM OF OF WHAT LONG WITH A TEAM
OF NINE STAFF MEMBERS. TO MSW
INTO AND PROBABLY FORTY
VOLUNTEERS THIRTEEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS ACROSS THE TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE MILE IF YOU EVER
DIFFERENT STEPS TO BAY AREA AND
UC DAVIS THAT'S MY AREA.
THE CASES WE DEAL WITH RANGE
FROM HOSPITAL DISCHARGES TO
HOMELESS SHELTERS ARE KEEPING
RESIDENTS WHO SUDDENLY WITH RATE
INCREASES. HORRIBLE INCIDENTS OF
ABUSE NEGLECT WHICH REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANTLY GAZE WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS IS MUCH MORE
THAN COLD COFFEE AND FINDING LOS
PURSES. THE WORK HAS BECOME MORE
SIGNIFICANT AND THE TRAINING FOR
VOLUNTEERS REQUIRE SPENT TIME
OVERSIGHT AND CARE MANAGEMENT
FOR THEM BECAUSE THE THINGS WE
HEAR ABOUT.
I CANNOT HEREBY GRANDMOTHER
BEING ABUSED AND NEGLECTED AND
NOT TAKE THAT HOME AT NIGHT.
THE FUNDING I RECEIVE AYE AYE MY
BUDGET EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS THAN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT COMES WITH
THE SOURCES THROUGH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT AGING. I'M ABLE TO
FUNDRAISE FOR THE REST OF IT BUT
WITHOUT THAT MONEY I WILL DO
STAFF MEMBERS. LAST NIGHT MY
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT GAVE
HER NOTICE BECAUSE I CANNOT PAY
HER AS MUCH OF THE COMPANY IN MY
AREA COUNT THIS MONEY IS
CRITICAL FOR THE SUPPORT MY
AGENCY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TYRION
BECKNER I'M AN MSW INTERN WORK
AND ON THE CALL HEALTHY ON THE
TWO THIRDS OF THE CONTRA COSTA
AND SOLANO. AND. I'VE SEEN A LOT
NOW AND WORKING IN THE LONG TERM
CARE SYSTEM AND TO THINK THAT
HAVE BEEN REALLY SHOCKING THAT
IT STOOD OUT TO ME THE FIRST OF
THAT SIXTY PERCENT OF LONG TERM
CARE RESIDENTS DON'T RECEIVE ANY
VISIT FROM FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THAT MEANS THAT THE OMBUDSMAN.
ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO ARE
WORKING TO EMPOWER AN ADVOCATE
FOR THEM THE SECOND IS IN
WORKING AND RESIDENTS THE FEAR
THAT THEY HAVE A RETALIATION
COMING FORWARD. THERE'S A HUGE
NEED FOR THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE I HOPE WE SUPPORT.
AND KIM.
I KRISTA TELLING ME THIS SENIOR
ADVOCACY SERVICES FROM CINEMA
COUNTY ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
CALCUTTA CLOSER. I'M I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST PUT UP LAST YEAR WE
INVEST A INVESTIGATED OVER NINE
HUNDRED CASES IN JUST CINEMA
COUNTY I'VE TO HONOR FACILITIES
THAT. YOU DO THE MATH ON THAT
I'M TOUCHING OVER TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT WHICH MEANS RESOLVING
SOME SICK
PICK AN ISSUE WITH THEM.
I ALSO DISLIKE TO PUT THIS IN
YOUR THINKING ABOUT THE
VOLUNTEERS AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ON TEARS IF YOU SET A ROOM WITH
A HUNDRED PEOPLE AND SAID PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
GO INTO A NURSING HOME TO
INVESTIGATE ELDER ABUSE. THINK
ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD
RAISE THEIR HAND.
MINUTE REALISTICALLY THE.
TRYING TO FIND VOLUNTEERS AND
THEN.
MAINTAIN THEM AND KEEP
PORTING SERVICES IS A HUGE
ENDEAVOR CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT IT IS A SPECIAL PERSON WHO
DOES THIS SO.
I THINK YOUR FOR YOUR PAST
SUPPORT IN YOUR FUTURES.
EGGMAN.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I WANNA ASK
FOR SUPPORT FOR THIS COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT PREVENTS
PROBLEMS IN OUR ON LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES IT HAS PROVEN
RESULTS IN A BURKE AT AMP
DISTORTS OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF CALPE SINCE
SUPPORT.
SO NERVOUS
MY NAME IS SUSIE FRAZIER ON THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR HUMBOLDT
COUNTY DON'T NORTON TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FIFTEEN
HUNDRED RESIDENTS IN HUMBOLDT
AND DON'T MARK COUNTY WHO THINK
THEIR VOICES ARE NO LONGER
HEARD.
I WON INTRODUCED YOU TO THESE
RESIDENTS THEY ARE YOUR BOY
SCOUT YOUR GIRL SCOUT LEADERS
YOUR TEACHERS THE MOM NEXT DOOR
WHO ALWAYS HAD COOKIES READY FOR
YOU BECAUSE YOU WERE A LATCH KEY
KID. WE ARE THE ONES IN THERE
WORKING WITH THEM BECAUSE THEIR
FAMILIES ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
THERE ANYMORE.
I HAVE CURRENTLY SIX VOLUNTEERS
AND I HAVE TO FIGHT TO HANG ON
TO THEM WE SERVE DELMARK COUNTY
WHICH IS NOT THAT FAR AWAY
COMPARED TO MY COLLEAGUES. BUT
IT IS WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO UP ONE
ON ONE AND NEVER KNOW IF THE
ROADS GOING TO BE THERE WHEN YOU
COME HOME. SO I ENCOURAGE YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR PROGRAM WE
NEED YOU AND THEY NEED TO.
DON'T LET THEM THINK THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD ANYMORE PLEASE
THANK YOU.
AND YOU DID GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARY KAY WILLIAMS
OF VOLUNTEER FIELD OMBUDSMAN.
THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM SERVES A
VERY VULNERABLE POPULATION
PARTICULARLY THAT SIXTY PERCENT
OF RESIDENTS WITHOUT FAMILY
MEMBERS VISITING TO OBSERVE
CARE.
AND REPORT PROBLEMS AND YOU'VE
HEARD THAT SEVERAL TIMES THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM RESOLVES
COMPLAINTS AND MONITOR SAFETY TO
IMPROVE LIVES AND ALLEVIATE
SUFFERING.
PLEASE ADEQUATELY FUND THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
THANK YOU BECAME.
QUICKLY KITANA SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION.
I WANT TO ROB REQUESTS
THE SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
AND ALSO TO OUR EMPHASIZE WHAT
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY IN FOR SIZE
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE COUNTING ON US
THANK YOU. INCREMENT.
HEY I'M TRACY BARBER AND THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR OMBUDSMAN
SERVICES.
I SERVE THE FIVE MOST NORTHERN
COUNTIES.
SHAKING SORRY. LASSEN MODOC
CHEST ASSIST YOU AND TRINITY
COUNTIES.
WHERE THE THIRD LARGEST SERVICE
AREA IN CALIFORNIA WE COVER
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES?
IN THE LAST YEAR I'VE LOST FIVE
VOLUNTEERS.
BRINGS ME TO MY CURRENT NUMBER
OF SIX.
AND SEE I'M LOSING THEM.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE WORK THAT I'M
ASKING THEM TO DO IS BECOMING
TOO MUCH FO THEM THEY'RE NO
LONGER FRIENDLY VISITORS THAT'S
NOT A FUN JOB IT'S NOT WARM AND
FUZZY. AND.
AND WHEN THEY'RE IN THE
OUTLYING.
NORTHERN COUNTIES OF THE NOT
SHASTA BUT LASSEN MODOC CISCO.
THEY'RE NOT SUPPORTED BAIL THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO WALK
INTO THE OFFICE TO GET OUR
SUPPORT IT'S ALL A TELEPHONE.
ASSUMING WHERE IN THE OFFICE TO
BUILD ANSWER THE TELEPHONE AND
HELP THEM IT'S BECOMING A OUT OF
A BIG PROBLEM.
I'M SO WE DECIDED IT'S MORE
PRUDENT TO RETAIN THE CURRENT
VOLUNTEER STATUS THAT WE HAVE
AND WE'VE ASKED THEM JUST TO
BECOME FRIENDLY VISITORS AND
THAT LEAVES THE CASE MONITORS
THE OTHER KEYS INVESTIGATIONS.
TO MYSELF IN MY OTHER STAFF
MEMBER SO THAT TAKES US OUT OF
THE OFFICE EVEN MORE SO THAN WE
WERE BEFORE.
TIME AND LIKE OTHERS TWO YEARS
AGO WE GOT A LITTLE BIT EXTRA
FUNDING THAT WAS FANTASTIC THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WAS ABLE TO HIRE
AN EXTRA PERSON THREE QUARTER
TIME IN MY OFFICE. AND SHE
RECENTLY LEFT.
BECAUSE.
AS WE'RE GOING INTO THAT FIFTEEN
DOLLAR AN HOUR MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE.
SHE KNEW THAT I WAS IN ANOTHER
RETAIN HER
SO SHE FOUND ANOTHER JOB
ELSEWHERE.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING IN MY AREA PLEASE
SUPPORT OUR PROGRAMS ARE SO
CRUCIAL. THANK YOU IN HUMAN.
HIS STILL KELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING. HIM NO WE'RE
PROUD OF OUR LONGSTANDING A.
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM AND THE INVESTMENT
ASSOCIATION.
A LIKELY INVESTMENT PROGRAM
TRIPLE LASER ALSO COMMITTED.
TO THE DIGNITY AND SELF
DETERMINATION OF OUR RESIDENTS.
HE OMBUDSMAN VOLUNTEERS OUT
THERE DO THAT WELL AND WE REALLY
NEED TO SUPPORT HIM FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS CRUCIAL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON EILEEN KAMINSKY
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
COUNTY APS PROGRAMS JUST WORK
BETTER WE HAVE PROPERLY RESOURCE
TO LOCAL OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS.
AND SO WE REALLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST THANK
YOU THANK HIM.
CHAU POPE ALZHEIMER'S SERVICES
THAN THE EAST BAY EMPIRE ON
THAT'S MEN ON BOARD MEMBER AND
I'M HERE BECAUSE I REALLY AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CUTS THAT
THIS PROGRAM. BECAUSE OF THE
SENIORS WITH ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA LIVING AND ASSISTED
LIVING THEN BORDEN CARES WHO
CANNOT SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
I HAVE A FRIEND THAT IS LIVING
IN A BOARDING CARE NOW THAT.
WE MOVED HER TO BECAUSE WE WENT
TO THE ASSISTED LIVING THAT SHE
WAS LIVING AND SHE WAS FOUND
WITH BED BUGS.
AND I HAD FOUND OUT THAT A
NUMBER IT'S MEN HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO VISIT THAT PARTICULAR
FACILITY FOR OVER A YEAR AND
THAT'S HER CHAPLAIN AND PASTOR.
I WAS APPALLED.
ONE BECAUSE I SAT ON THE ARM
THAT'S A BIT MORE BOARD AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY THIS PROGRAM IS
SO VITAL TO BE THE VOICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES. AND IT'S
APPALLING THAT THERE ARE
FACILITIES WITHIN OUR STATE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED TO LIVE AND
AND THAT THERE'S NO CONTROL ON
HOW ON THEIR CARING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THOSE
BUILDINGS. THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
REALLY MAKE SURE ALONG WITH A P.
ASSN ALONG WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND
THAT BIG POSTER WITH THAT ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER IS SO
IMPORTANT SO PLEASE SAVE IT.
HENRIK IN TERMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
NANCY PARRISH CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND WE. ARE
REALLY HOPEFUL THAT YOU WILL
LOOK AT THIS AND THE FACT THAT
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY BASELINE
CHANGES SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. I THINK WE ALL LOOK AT
THAT AND SAY.
THAT'S WAY BACK IN THE TIME
MACHINE AND IT'S TIME TO BRING
THESE SERVICES UP. OF TO WHAT
THE POPULATION NEEDS AND
DESERVES AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK HIM.
MY NAME IS MELISSA FLAHERTY
YOUNG REPRESENTING THE COURT
ACCORDING TO FOR THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY. I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
THE SILICON VALLEY BUT LIVED IN
DOES THE ALBERT CULTURE VALLEY
FOR THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS I
LEARNED TO APPRECIATE. THE FOLKS
THERE THAT FORMER TO TABLE COUNT
OCONEE IS HAS IS SO WONDERFUL
THE FOLKS THERE ARE HARD WORKING
PEOPLE. EVEN THOUGH SOME OF
THOSE FOLKS MIGHT END UP IN
REHAB OR LONG TERM ASSISTED
LIVING OR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY SOME OF THOSE DON'T
HAVE REPRESENTATION. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THIS A WOMAN
THAT WAS.
HAD A FORM WITH THEIR PARENTS
SHE DEDICATED HER WHOLE LIFE.
TO HER FARM WITH HER PARENTS AND
HAD NO ONE THERE TO REPRESENT
HER AND FORTUNATE THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM WAS THERE FOR HER.
THE US THE THIS UP PROGRAM ON
THE TO PROGRAM IS IMPLEMENTED
LOOK MANY MANY YEARS AGO AND
WITH THE COST AT THAT TIME. NOW
THE COST IS CHANGE
THE EMBITTERED PROGRAM AND THIS
INCREASE IS REASONABLE TO THE.
IT COST EFFECTIVE THIS TO THE
STATE.
THANK YOU
EGGMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN THE MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WELL OVER FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE RESIDENTS AND OUR
STATES ARE CMP'S. AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES HAVE A
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT. AND MANY
OF THEM ARE ON REPRESENTED IN
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM IN OUR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WE
SUPPORT THAT SPENDING REQUEST
THINKING.
WHY CAN'T EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THEY TRIPLE A OF SANTA CRUZ AND
SAN BENITO COUNTIES ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AND I THINK
THIS ON BUT THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM HIGHLIGHTS KIND OF OUR
INTERNAL FLAW IN ALL THESE AGING
PROGRAMS?
THE DAY RELY TREMENDOUSLY ON
VOLUNTEERS TO PROVIDE WHAT'S
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL SERVICE AND I
DON'T THINK ANY PROGRAM
EXEMPLIFIES THAT BETTER THAN
OMBUDSMAN. AND IT'S TRAGIC THAT
EVEN ON TOP OF THAT ARE WITHIN
THAT DESIGN WE HAVE TO STRUGGLE
FOR EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR FOR
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS I'M JUST
ONE PERSONAL COMMENTS. ON
SPEAKING TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO'S COMMENT ABOUT LONELINESS
AND ISOLATION.
OMBUDSMAN PAYS PLAYS A HUGE ROLE
IN THIS AND ONE OF MY FONDEST
MEMORIES OF VISITING MY MOM IN
NURSING HOMES.
WOULD BE WHEN SHE WOULD SAY
ALTHOUGH THERE WAS JUST SOMEBODY
HERE FROM AN OFFICE THAT KNOWS
YOU AND SHE WOULD MEAN THE
OMBUDSMAN PERSON THAT IT STOP BY
TO SAY HI.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT'S JUST AN
ADDED VALUE TO THE PROGRAM
OFFERS I'M INJURED THEN JUST
LASTLY I'M WHAT PRICE TO BE PUT
ON ELDER ABUSE I DON'T THINK
THERE SHOULD BE ANY.
THINK IS SEX.
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
ECHOES THE.
.
THOUGHTS OF EACH OF THE
PRESENTERS
THAT I'VE SPOKEN HERE HANDLE WE
FULLY SUPPORT.
FUNDING OF THE A LONG TERM CARE
PROGRAM.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT ON
PUBLIC OUR OWN ISSUE THREE I'LL
BRING IT BACK
THE DYESS FRONT.
SEEING NONE I HAVE A FEW.
HOPE PLEASE. PUT OUT FOR I JUST
WANT SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE
OF YOU WHO TRAVELED FAR AND WIDE
TO PASS TO DELIVER THIS MESSAGE
AND.
AND TRUST WE WE HEAR YOU
ABSOLUTELY AND I'M. NOT
REPRESENTING.
AN AREA THAT IS A VERY RURAL
DISTRICT.
WITH WITH JUST LIMITED SERVICES
AND CHALLENGES IN GENERAL.
THESE THESE ISSUES ARE REALLY
REALLY CUTE AND THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS A REALLY VALUABLE
COMPONENT. OF FOR US IN OUR IN
IN MY DISTRICT AND SO SO WHY WHY
WHY WILL BE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING
REQUEST BECAUSE I THERE IS THAT
THERE IS A HUGE VALUE TO TO THE
FOLKS.
WHO WHO UTILIZE YOUR THIS
SERVICE OR THAT YOU THAT YOU
HELPED TO THEIR SERVICES?
AND I GO BACK TO I THINK WE ARE
JUDGED BY HOW WE CARE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND AND AND I FOR
ONE WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
FOR LEASE A COMMON I HAVE A
QUESTION WHAT WOULD THE EFFECTS
ON PRESENCE IN FREQUENCY FOR
PROBLEM FACILITIES BE UNDER YOUR
PROPOSAL.
I'M SORRY SAY THE QUESTION AGAIN
WHAT WOULD THE AFFECTS ON
PRESENTS AND FREQUENCY FOR
PROBLEM FACILITIES BE UNDER YOUR
PROPOSAL.
WELL THAT'S GOOD OKAY.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT.
I SAN LUIS OBISPO PROGRAM ARE
SAN LUIS OBISPO PROGRAM IS
PROBABLY OUR BEST FUNDED PROGRAM
IF NOT IN THE STATE IN THE
NATION.
AA SENIOR DIED AND LEFT THE
PROGRAM OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
AND SO THAT PROGRAM GETS LESS
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN STATE AND FEDERAL MONEY AND
THEN THEY DREW DOWN OFF OF THAT
MILLION DOLLARS. SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO GO FROM ONE POINT FIVE
EMPLOYEES TO THREE EMPLOYEES
THEY WENT FROM NINE VOLUNTEERS
TO TWENTY SEVEN VOLUNTEERS THEY
WENT FROM ELEVEN HUNDRED
FACILITY VISITS TO TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED FACILITY VISITS.
AND YES THE COMPLAINT NUMBERS
WENT FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO NINE
HUNDRED.
BUT THE KEY FACTOR.
THAT I REALLY WANT TO DRILL
DOWN.
THEY WENT FROM TWENTY SIX
COMPLAINTS OF ELDER ABUSE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE SEVERE
ENOUGH THAT REQUIRED LICENSING
INTERVENTION.
THEY WENT FROM TWENTY SIX DOWN
TO FOUR.
SO EVEN IF YOU DON'T FACTOR IN
THE HUMAN THAT TWENTY TWO PEOPLE
DID NOT EXPERIENCE BAT.
TRUMP TRAUMA.
HOW MUCH DID IT SAY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT TO HAVE STATE
EMPLOYEES TRAVELING BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO LOCAL LICENSING
OFFICES IN SAN LUIS OBISPO?
EVERYONE OF THOSE REQUIRE IT
LEAST A FOUR HOUR DRIVE FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AT
POTENTIALLY HOTEL STAY.
SO.
HOW IS IT GOING TO CHANGE?
THE THE CLIMATE IN THE
FACILITIES.
THERE IS GOING TO THERE'S GOING
TO BE A CULTURAL CHANGE.
TOWARDS EMBRACING A.
RESIDENT CENTERED CARE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
OMBUDSMAN STILL WE DON'T SITE
FACILITIES WE DON'T COME IN WITH
A CITATION BOOK WE'RE NOT BEAR
TO TO. ARREST ANYONE WERE
WALKING GOOGLE ON WHAT THE RULES
ARE AND SO YOU EMPOWER THE
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS TO KNOW WHAT THOSE RULES
ARE. AND ULTIMATELY THAT
FACILITY KINDA GOES ALONG WITH
IT BECAUSE IT GETS TIRING TO
HAVE A PERSON LIKE ME COME BACK
EVERY SINGLE WEEK GOING YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE REALLY CAN'T GIVE
AMAT THUGS GOOD NO I'M JUST NOT
GONNA LET YOU DO IT EVERY NIGHT
I'M GONNA COME BACK AND. SAY
THAT'S NOT OKAY.
SO.
IT'S THE THE PRESENCE OF THAT
NAGGING WATER DRIPPING THAT
MAKES YOU CHANGE.
NOT THAT MY OMBUDSMAN'S ARE
NAGGING ON. THEY'RE LOVELY
PEOPLE.
PREFERRED MENGES NINJAS THEY ARE
NINJAS.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTIONS
CAN YOU PLEASE COMMENT ON ONE
TIME FUNDING IN YOUR VIEW OF
THIS PROPOSAL WHY WOULD IT WORK
OR NOT.
TO SAY THAT I'M NOT GRATEFUL FOR
ONE TIME FUNDING WOULD BE OF AN
UNDERSTATEMENT ONE TIME FUNDING
HAS ALLOWED US TO TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN AND HAS. GIVEN US THE
OPPORTUNITY AND TO TO INVEST IN
A MORE COMPUTERS AND TO TO HAVE.
BETTER.
PHONE SYSTEMS ARE LARGER
PROGRAMS CAN USE THAT MONEY TO
HIRE STAFF BECAUSE THEY CAN.
BACK FILL UNTIL THAT ONE TIME
MONEY ACTUALLY HITS THE PROGRAM
BUDGET.
BUT OUR SMALLER PROGRAMS JUST
CAN'T.
.
THE MONEY MAY BE IN THE JULY
BUDGET BUT IT'S NOT IN THEIR
CONTRACT THAT STARTED IN JULY.
SO YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING STARTS THEIR
CONTRACT PERIOD WHICH IS THE END
OF SEPTEMBER. AND THEN THEY HAVE
NINETY DAYS IN WHICH THEY'RE
ENTERING A CONTRACT WITH THE
TRIP LAYS AND THEN THE TRIPLE
A.'S GET NINETY DAYS TO ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT WITH THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. SO WHILE WE
ARE APPRECIATIVE THAT WE GOT A
MILLION DOLLARS ON JULY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WE HAVE
LOCAL PROGRAMS IS STILL HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ANY OF THEIR SHARE. YET.
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES TO GET THE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE NEGATIVE
ASPECTS OF ONE FAMILY MONEY
YOU'RE HIRING SOMEONE WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING WORKING TO KEEP
YOU FOR MAYBE. NINE MONTHS AND
THEN WE GONNA LET YOU GO.
THE OTHER PART OF.
PROBLEM OF ONE TIME MANY IS WE
DON'T HAVE ONE TIME ONLY
PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
ONGOING.
AND.
IT.
YES IF YOU GAVE ME TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR VOLUNTEER I
RECRUITED PROGRAM THAT BE GREAT.
BUT IT WOULD TAKE US TIME TO
CREATE THE COLLATERAL TO CREATE
THE THE THE.
THE ABILITY TO TO ACTUALLY GET
THOSE VOLUNTEERS IN THE DOOR.
SO WE MIGHT RUN OUT OF TIME
BEFORE WE WE RAN OUT OF THOSE
DOLLARS IT IF THEY WERE JUST IN
THAT AREA.
BUT I THINK.
ALSO SOMETIMES ONE TIME MONEY
HARMS US.
A FEW YEARS BACK THE VENTURA
PROGRAM RECEIVED A GRANT THAT
THEY BELIEVE WOULD BE ONGOING IN
NATURE. AND THE GRANT WAS
DIRECTED TOWARDS RESIDENTS THAT
WERE NON ENGLISH SPEAKING.
AND SO THAT PROGRAM CREATED
COLLATERAL POSTERS FLYERS TO
PROMOTE ON THIS AND ACTIVITIES
FOR OUR SPANISH A SPEAKING
RESIDENTS. THE THE LOCAL PROGRAM
HIRED AND TRAINED SPANISH
SPEAKING OMBUDSMAN
AND THEN JUST AS THE PHONE CALLS
ARE STARTIN TO COME THEN. THE
FUNDING WAS NOT RENEWED FOR THE
NEXT YEAR.
BUT ALL THOSE POSTERS WERE STILL
UP IN THE IN THOSE FACILITIES.
AND WE HAD TO LET THOSE VIOLENT
WE HAD TO LET THE STAFF GO THAT
WERE SPANISH SPEAKING. BUT FOR
MANY MONTHS TO COME.
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WERE VERY FRUSTRATED TO CALL THE
LOCAL OFFICE AND FIND OUT THAT
THIS REALLY GREAT INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE
WAS NO LONGER THERE. I THINK IN
SOME WAYS.
IT DOES HARM.
WHEN WE CAN'T.
FOLLOW THROUGH.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT FEEL LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BUT HOW DOES THIS
PROPOSAL ONLINE OR NOT WITH THE
STATE PLAN.
JODY ONE SPEAK TO THAT SURE.
AS A DIRECTOR CONNELLY INDICATED
EARLIER.
THE OBJECTIVES IN THE STATE PLAN
REALLY ADDRESS WHAT WE CAN DO
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES IT
DOESN'T COUNTENANCE.
AND A SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR BANK TATIAN.
.
AS LIZA INDICATED WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE THE ONE TIME ONLY
MONEY THAT WE'VE RECEIVED IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS. AND CERTAINLY
WE COULD USE THE MONEY.
BUT.
.
AND LISA SAID.
IT WOULD BE FOR ONE YEAR.
AND THE PROBLEMS WOULD REMAIN.
FOR FINANCE CAN YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTATIVES
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THE LA L.
ABOUT THE NECESSARY.
NECESSITY FOR AND FUNCTIONING OF
THE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE CHANGES.
AND THEN. FINALLY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN
FACILITATING.
AS MUCH OF THE TRANSFER IN THE
ACCOUNTS AS AS REASONABLE AS A
WAY TWO PARTIALLY RESPONDS TO
THE NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO CONSIDERING THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
.
AND GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR SHOW.
ARE YOU ONE OF THE.
OKAY.
ISSUE FOUR WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH DUSTIN HARPER.
AND THEN LIKE DENISE LIKE OR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
GARDEN THE PROPOSED RATE
INCREASE FOR HIM SAYS BE
PROGRAM.
MY NAME'S DUSTIN HARPER AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AND
SISKIYOU SIDE ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE INSTITUTE ON AGING.
PROVIDER ABOUT SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE BECAUSE MY SITE UNLIKE
MOST OTHER MISSISSIPPI SITES
THAT RISK OF CLOSING ITS DOORS
THIS NEXT YEAR.
IN THE FACE OF RAPIDLY GROWING
COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
THIS PROGRAM HASN'T HAD A RATE
INCREASE IN TWELVE YEARS.
AND BY FAR NUMBER ONE COST
DRIVERS THE SALARIES. AND
BENEFITS OF OUR NURSES AND
SOCIAL WORKERS.
IS NURSES AND SOCIAL WORKERS
SPEND THEIR DAYS.
SERVING LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS
IN THEIR HOMES.
AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THEY'RE
THE PRIMARY BARRIER BETWEEN
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND LONG TERM
CARE NURSING HOME PLACEMENT.
THESE ARE CHALLENGING JOBS IN
NURSES CORRECTLY EXPECT LEVELS
OF
QUALITY AND PERFORMANCE FROM
THESE NURSES AND SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE WORK THEY DO.
THE FIFTIETH PERCENTILE OF
NURSING AND SOCIAL WORK
COMPENSATION IS INCREASED BY
MORNING THIRTY PERCENT THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS.
EVEN THE MOST WELL INTENTIONED
ORGANIZATION CAN'T CONTINUE TO
OPERATE PROGRAM OR COSTS RISE
BY.
MORETHAN THIRTY PERCENT ALONG
ZERO PERCENT INCREASE ON THE
REVENUE SIDE.
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM NOW TALK
TO GREAT LENGTHS
REGARDING.
THE GROWING NEED FOR SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
AND MISSISSIPPI IS ONE OF THOSE
SOLUTIONS.
AND THIS IS BE CARE MANAGERS
CONNECT BENEFICIARIES TO NEEDED
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
THEY ASSIST INDIVIDUALS AND
NAVIGATING THE MEDICAL AND
SOCIAL SERVICE SYSTEMS OF CARE.
AND WHEN THERE IS NOT AN
AVAILABLE RESOURCE TO MEET THE
NEEDS AND ASSIST BE CARE
MANAGERS PURCHASE GOODS AND
SERVICES FOR THEIR CLIENTS.
NOT THAT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING REGARDING. THE
ROLE OF THE OMBUDSMAN PLAY.
AND ASSIST BE CARE MANAGERS ALSO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CLIENTS WHEN THEY'RE IN THE
HOME.
THIS IS WHAT ADDRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH LOOKS
LIKE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT ARE
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS BELIEVE IN.
AND ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO
DO WELL.
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS TO HAVE OUR
REVENUE KEEP UP WITH THE RISING
COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
I MISSISSIPPI'S ALSO VALUABLE
ALTERNATIVE LONG TERM CARE
UTILIZATION.
VENICE SP IS SUCCESSFUL IN
DELAYING LONG TERM CARE
PLACEMENT FOR JUST FIVE PERCENT
OF ITS POPULATION.
IT'S MONTH THE PAYS FOR ITSELF.
WE APPRECIATE CONSIDERING THE
FUNDING REQUEST AND
PLEASE LET US OUT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT WE
CAN.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON DENISE LIKER
INDEPENDENCE AT HOME ON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I REPRESENT ONE
OF THE LAW ONE OF THE. OLDEST MS
US P. SITES IN THE STATE A WE
ARE ONE OF THE FIRST DEMO SITES
IT'S FORTY YEARS AGO THAT WE
STARTED AND WE ARE STILL DOING
IT TODAY.
I'M I'M HERE BUT TODAY ECHOING
I'M.
WELL MISTER HARPER IS.
.
IT IS IS TALKING ABOUT ABOUT OUR
FUNDING REQUEST.
PUT IT IN CONTEXT OF THE
TYPICAL PROFILE OF AN MS AS P.
CLIENT IS A FEMALE IN HER
EIGHTIES.
LIVES ALONE.
PROBABLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY
CHILDREN OR IF SHE DOES THEY'RE
NOT LIVING IN THE AREA. SHE ONLY
HAS ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH.
TO LIVE ON.
SHE'S GOT FOUR TO FIVE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AND SHE'S GOT FOUR TO
FIVE MAYBE SIX. IMPAIRMENTS OF
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING SHE'S
TRYING TO EAT SHE'S TRYING TO
KEEP HEAT ON CHEESE TRYING TO
PAY RENT IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH AFFORDED WHICH IS A
PROBLEM IN OF ITSELF.
AND THEN THROW IN THAT SHE
PROBABLY SPEAKS A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH.
SO THIS IS THE POPULATION THAT
MS US PIAS THEREFORE IT'S A VERY
SMALL SEGMENT OF THE OLDER DOT
POPULATION.
BUT IT'S A NURSING HOME
CERTIFIED POPULATION THE CA
TOMORROW BE PUT INTO ONE OF
THOSE BEDS IF THERE WAS ONE
AVAILABLE EVEN.
AND BEFORE AND IT'S VERY HIDDEN
POPULATION.
SO FOR FORTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
OUT THERE DOING THIS AND
CONNECTING THEM.
SO ARE FUNDING INCREASE IF YOU
PUT IT IN CONTEXT OF NURSING
HOME DOLLARS.
THE FUNDING REQUEST THAT WERE
ASKING FOR FIFTY THREE FIFTY SIX
PER CLIENT PERSPECTIVE IT'S LOT
PER YEAR IF YOU PUT IT ON MEDI
CAL BEDS IN A NURSING HOME.
THERE'S AMEND SAVINGS THERE
ALREADY FROM WHAT IT COSTS TO BE
IN A NURSING HOME BED WHICH I
BELIEVE IS OWE THE MEDI CAL RATE
IS ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND PER
YEAR FOR A BED.
SO THERE'S THERE'S A THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS SAVINGS OUR STAFF OUR
HANDS AND FEET ON THE GROUND.
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE ON THE
GROUND IN THEIR IN THE HOME THEY
SEE EVERYTHING THE ADDRESS
EVERYTHING.
FREE RESOURCES AS WELL AS
CONNECTING.
SO WE'RE REALLY LOOKING.
SHORE UP THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE
WHERE THE PROGRAM OF LAST RESORT
THE PEOPLE COME TO US UNDER
THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE TO GO
THEY'VE BEEN TURNED AWAY THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND THEM. ARE QUITE
FRANKLY THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS WHERE TO GO FOR SERVICES.
SO THAT'S OUR FIRST REQUEST
IT TODAY IS IS IS WE NEED HELP
SHORING UP THIS PROGRAM SO THAT
PROVIDERS LIKE MYSELF AND THE
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE
SERVICES. FOR POPULATION HAS
NOWHERE ELSE TO GO.
THE OTHER ITEM UP YOUR TO
ADDRESS TODAY AS I KNOW IN THE
AGENDA.
THERE IS A LANGUAGE BUT
ACCORDING TO CARE INITIATIVE OF
WHICH MS US P. IS ALSO BEEN
INVOLVED IN.
AND.
.
I'M SURE THE ADMINISTRATION THEM
AND STILL NEEDS TO REPORT OUT ON
PROGRESS SO I'M HOPING I'M NOT
STEALING ANYBODY'S THUNDER BUT
I'M LAST YEAR WE WERE HERE FOR.
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
IN ORDER TO BE WORKING ON.
ON THIS
FOR THIS BONNEVILLE POPULATION
BEING ABLE A PLAN ACCORDINGLY
BECAUSE MANAGED CARE QUITE
FRANKLY HAS NOT TAKEN CARE OF
THIS POPULATION.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND CONVERSATIONS HAVE RESUMED
AND THERE ARE NEW PLAYERS AT THE
TABLE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT TRANSITION WILL LOOK
LIKE IN WHAT THE FUTURE MAY
HOLD.
BUT WE DO HAVE A FEW CAUTIONS
AND SO WE HAVE EAGER LEAVE BEEN
INVOLVED.
IN TRYING TO MOVE IN TRYING TO
SEE THE RIGHT PATH FORWARD AND
HONORING THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT FROM WAY BACK TWENTY
TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE WAS
PASSED.
IN ORDER TO HAVE THEM ASSESS P.
WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH MANAGED
CARE.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
THE FOUNDATION OF LEARNING
TOGETHER WHAT IT TAKES TO TAKE
CARE OF THIS POPULATION SINCE WE
HAD THE EXPERIENCE.
AND LATER IN THAT FOUNDATION OF
INFORMATION DATA AND LEARNING.
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD THE FUTURE
OF MS US P. FMS WERE TO GO INTO
MANAGED CARE.
THREE YEARS HAVE GONE BY AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OF THAT IN THE PLACE THE
FOUNDATION IS NOT THEY ARE. AT
THIS POINT
WE HAVE TWENTY MONTHS LEFT
AND ALTHOUGH CONVERSATIONS HAVE
RESUMED WHICH OUR WONDERFUL.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW IS
TRANSITION PLANNING WITHOUT A
FOUNDATION TWENTY TO
CHARACTERIZE IT LIKE BUILDING A
HOUSE?
YOU BUILD A HOUSE ON A VERY
STRONG FOUNDATION.
IF YOU DON'T BUILD IT ON A VERY
STRONG FOUNDATION BAD THINGS CAN
HAPPEN.
AND SO WHEN YOU THINK OF THIS
FRAIL VERY VULNERABLE POOR
POPULATION WE'VE GOTTA GET IT
RIGHT FOR THEM SO WE ARE OUT ON
BEHALF OF THEM A SAY IN THE CCI
SITES WE ARE HERE WE WILL.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEGUN BUT WE
ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE WE CAN'T
GET BACK THE THREE YEARS THAT
ARE GONE.
AND SO WE MAY BE BACK TO NEED
SOME HELP AND ASSISTANCE.
.
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS THE RIGHT
PATH SO WE DON'T GET IT WRONG
FOR THE FRAIL PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR CALMLY.
YES THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM THE PANELISTS A IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE EMPHASIS P. PROGRAM
PROVIDES FOR MANY OF WHICH IS
THAT AS A CABBIE OUT FOR MANY OF
THE PARTICIPANTS ON WELL OVER
EIGHTY. EIGHTY PERCENT THEY ARE
ENROLLED IN THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM BUT
REALLY NEED THAT EXTRA LEVEL IN
TERMS OF CARE COORDINATION.
OTHER PURCHASE SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT THEM THAT THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM
WOULD NOT PROVIDE. SO REALLY
THIS IS IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
GRADATION IN TERMS OF. BEING
ABLE TO STAY IN THE HOME YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S THAT CONTINUUM
IN TERMS OF THE SERVICES.
UNDER CURRENT LEE I JUST PUT ON
WHAT ASCETIC CONTEXT
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
IT SEEMS EVERY TIME WE'VE COME
TO TESTIFY ABOUT MS SP. IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT IN RELATION TO
SEE SEE IAM THE ROLLOUT AND A
SEVEN COUNTIES THEY'RE CURRENTLY
THIRTY EIGHT EMESIS P. SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I'M SERVING APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND POUND CLIENTS PER YEAR
THAT EQUATES TO NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED SOME ODD SLOTS.
I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE
NOT THE SLOTS BUT IT'S THE WAY
IT WORKS.
AS I AS DENISE MENTIONED AND.
AND I DID AS WELL IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE COORDINATED
CARE INITIATIVE REALLY
ENVISIONED. THAT THE CARE OF
THAT THE MANAGED CARE PLANS THAT
WOULD BE WORKING WITH THE I.
MISSISSIPPI SITES AND AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE.
THAT CARE MANAGEMENT SERVICE OF
WOULD BE TRANSFERRING TO THE
HEALTH PLANS.
.
THAT DOES THERE ARE TWELVE AND
MISSISSIPPI SITES IN THOSE
SEVEN.
COUNTIES SIGH I JUST WANTED SET
THAT IN IN TERMS OF A CAVIAR.
THE TRANSITION DALY ARM FOR.
THE HEALTH PLANS TO ASSUME.
THAT RESPONSIBILITY IS BASED ON
HOW PLAN READINESS TO DO SO.
AND.
HAS BEEN UPDATED OVERTIME ARM
AND A SET FOR NO SOONER THAN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
.
BUT EVEN SHOULD THAT OCCUR AT
THAT POINT IN TIME.
THERE WILL STILL BE TWENTY SIX
NEMESIS P. SITES.
WITH FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED.
SOME ODD SLOTS OUTSIDE THOSE CCI
COUNTIES.
THAT WILL BE CONTINUING TO
OPERATE AND PART OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF AGING
ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN THE.
PROCESS FOR RENEWING THEM
NEMESIS P. WAY FOR YOU KNOW ARE
ON AN ONGOING BASIS IN TERMS OF
THAT. SO I JUST WANTED TO PROM
BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE FOCUSED SO
MUCH ON.
RIGHTLY SO IN TERMS OF LOOKING
AT IT EMPHASIS BE WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF CCI WE'VE KIND OF
HAVEN'T BEEN TALKING ABOUT. THE
REST OF THE PROGRAM OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS JUST WANTED
TO WRITE THAT. THAT CAVIAR.
THANK YOU.
I'M WEEK NEXT HAVE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FUJIMOTO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR WE MAY MOVE ON NO NO
CUT NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME THEN
IF WE CAN MAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
SPACE FOR SARAH BROOKS FROM PHD
S..
BUT I PUT IT UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR BROOKS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
I'M I DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS I THINK
DIRECTOR CONLEY AND LAID IT OUT
BAD WELL I DO WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE FACT THAT.
THAT THE THE.
.
TRANSITION OF.
EMESIS PIZZA MANAGED CARE HAS
BEEN PUSHED BACK SEVERAL TIMES
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT THAT'S
WHY OUR WORK PLAN ITSELF HAS
ALSO BEEN DELAYED WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING AND WHAT THE EMPHASIS
BESIDES AN ASSOCIATION TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A SOLID PLAN
IN PLACE AYE WHEN WE DO
TRANSITION IN AND NO SOONER THAN
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN THE COMMENTS.
BELIAU.
SEEING KNOW HOW WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
JANET HEATH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THE AND ASSIST DECIDE
ASSOCIATION.
JUST ONE OTHER POINT OUT THAT AS
YOU HEARD THERE THIRTY EIGHT
SITES THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
WITH THE MISSISSIPPI. THAT
ACTUALLY SERVES FORTY SEVEN
COUNTIES BOTH RURAL AND URBAN.
SO WE COVER MOST OF THE STATE OF
THIS POINT.
AS YOU HEARD WE HAVE HAD AN
INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX.
THE SAME TIME THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS HAD AN INFLATION
RATE OF TWENTY THREE PERCENT.
SOURCE FACING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTIES WITH OUR FINANCING.
REGULATORY LIMITATIONS.
IN WHICH IN MISSISSIPPI
PROVIDERS CANNOT MAKE UP FOR
PROGRAM DEFICITS INCLUDE.
INCREASING OR DECREASING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THEY SERVE.
REDUCING PROGRAM SERVICES
SERVING PRIVATE PAY CONSUMERS OR
HIRING LESS QUALIFIED STAFF
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE CANNOT
DO.
BECAUSE THE REGULATIONS.
IN OUR ATTEMPT TO TRY TO MAKE DO
WITH WHAT WE HAVE WE'VE REDUCE
STAFF.
WE'VE REDUCED THE HOURS TO THE
STAFF THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RETAIN. WE'VE PROVIDED NO OR
MINIMAL SALARY INCREASES.
AND SOME OF THE SITE DIRECTORS
ARE CURRENTLY NOT RECEIVING ANY
SALARY FROM THE IN MISSISSIPPI
PROGRAM.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR MONEY FROM OTHER SOURCES.
HOST ORGANIZATIONS ARE
SUPPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM BY.
BETWEEN SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN THE CLOSURE IN TURN OVER OF
ELEVEN SITES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THIS FACT THAT HOST AGENCIES ARE
UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPLEMENT THE PROGRAM.
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
THE FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSE THINK YOU.
KIM.
HELLO I'M JOHN DILUTES EXECUTIVE
HEALTH PROJECTS AND WE RUN THE.
BOTTOM I MISSISSIPPI'S FOR SANTA
CRUZ AND MONTEREY COUNTIES AND
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I CAN TELL
YOU THAT NONE OF OUR STAFF WILL
GET RAISES THIS YEAR LAST WEEK
AT ONE PERCENT. AND WILL BE
CUTTING BENEFITS ON TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM SO I FINALLY
OUT THERE THAT OUT THERE IN THAT
TWELVE YEARS OF. YOU KNOW
FUNDING CUTS HAVE IMPACTS ON YOU
KNOW BOTH GOOD PEOPLE WHO DO IT
AS WELL AS THE CLIENTS WE SERVE.
I'M NOT A MORE POSITIVE NOTE.
I WAS JUST RECENTLY AT ONE OF
OUR CLIENTS HOMES WHOM WE HAD
HELPED WITH THAT WITH ANOTHER
PROGRAM TO GET OUT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY HE'D BEEN THERE
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
BOB DIDN'T WANNA LIVE THERE IT'S
A MALE HE'S YOUNG IN A
WHEELCHAIR TO THEM HAVE FAMILY
AROUND HAVE A LOT OF ISSUES
THERE.
AND HE TOLD ME YOU KNOW AND HAD
TEARS IN HIS EYES THEY SAY
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM SOMETHING
TO HELP ME. IN THE COMMUNITY
GETTING OUT THERE'D STILL BE IN
PRISON THAT RECALL THAT HE SAYS
PREDICT I DON'T WANT TO BE
THERE.
SO PROGRAMS LIKE THIS ARE REALLY
WE DO GREAT THINGS FOR PEOPLE
AND REALLY HELP WHEN HE ASKED ME
TO TAKE. YOU KNOW EVERYBODY FOR
YOU KNOW THE GOOD WORK OF.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
HELPING MAKE THAT POSITIVE.
DAWN DO YOU HAVE THAT HAPPEN IF
HIS LIFE WAS REALLY LIFE
CHANGING AND WE'RE GONNA BE
THERE TO HELP AND SUPPORT HIM.
NO LONGER ZEKE CAN HOPEFULLY
TILL.
NINA DELUDE PASSES THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE THEIR FOURTH NOT EASY WORK
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WORK.
AND THEN A FINAL POSITIVE NOTE
COME I DID WANT TO SAY THAT.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND SUPPORT
THIS.
INCREASED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
MATCH IT.
THIS IS THIS IS NOW ONE OF THE
ISSUES WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING NO I DON'T DO
THIS THEY WILL MATCHES AT THE
PROGRAM. THROUGH MEDICAID.
CELL I RAN THE DECISION.
TO DO THIS OR NOT RISE AND THE
PEOPLE LIVE IN PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK OUR SENIORS
DESERVE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LINDA EGGMAN AND I AM A
CARE MANAGEMENT SUPERVISOR AT
THE MS US P. SITE HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL SENIOR CARE NETWORK IN
PASADENA. SERVING THE SAN
GABRIEL.
AND PROMOTED VALLEY'S.
MY PARENTS.
RESIDE AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO'S.
DISTRICT.
AND I ONE OF MY ROLES IS.
WHAT MY OTHER ROLES IS ALSO A
CAREGIVER TO MY PARENTS?
I EIGHT.
TOTALLY SUPPORT.
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
STATED AND I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE MS US P.? OF FUNDING
REQUEST OF FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
.
A CAREGIVER YOU NOW THAN.
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF OUR
OLDER ADULTS IS SOMETHING VERY
DEAR TO ME PERSONALLY.
PROFESSIONALLY.
OUR CLIENTS I THINK AS DENISE
HAD MENTIONED.
HAVE MULTIPLE CHRONIC DISEASES
AND PHYSICAL IMPAIRMENTS
AND WHEN WE MEET THEM WE.
HELP THEM WE HELP OUR CLIENTS
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES SUCH
AS. LOU A LITTLE TO NO SUPPORT
IN PLACE.
ARE HOME ALONE.
ISOLATION. TOM AND ALSO IN
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
SERVICES LIKE DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT.
IN ORDER TO HELP THEM MANAGE
THEIR DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CLAY CAM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIALIZATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND ALSO OUR
OWN TRIP AWAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL. I'M JUST A COUPLE OF
QUICK POINTS ONE IS BY
DEFINITION THIS PROGRAM SAVE THE
STATE MONEY.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON IT ARE
ELIGIBLE AND QUALIFIED TO BE IN
A NURSING HOME FOR A FRACTION OF
THAT COST THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
LIVE AT HOME SO BETTER QUALITY
OF LIFE.
SAVINGS TO THE STATE EVERY YEAR
THE COST OF STAYING IN NURSING
HOMES GOES UP SO IT MAKES NO
SENSE NOT TO GIVE A CONSTANT
CREES FOR THE PROGRAM. THAT
KEEPS PEOPLE OUT OF THOSE
NURSING HOME.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED ARE MORE MS
AS P. SLOTS IN THE STATE BUT
THAT OBVIOUSLY CAN'T HAPPEN
UNLESS THE EXISTING ONES ARE
FUNDED AT A LEVEL AT WHICH THEY
CAN SURVIVE SO WE ENCOURAGE?
THIS AUGMENTATION
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO AGAIN I'M JENNIFER PAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DIGNITY
HEALTH CONNECTED LIVING AND
AGAIN WE SERVE THE FIVE
NORTHERNMOST COUNTIES UP AND.
.
IN THE NORTHERN PART THE STATE.
I BECAME A SITE DIRECTOR
ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE OUR OUR SIDE
DIRECTOR WHO'D BEEN WITH OUR
PROGRAM FOR QUITE SOMETIME
RETIRED. AND QUITE FRANKLY WE
COULDN'T AFFORD TO TO FILL HIS
SLOT SO WHILE LA I AM NOW A SITE
DIRECTORS WELL AND.
SINCE DECEMBER SO IT'S BEEN
VERY.
IT'S ONLY BEEN FOUR MONTHS AND
SO INFORMANTS WHAT I'VE I'VE
REALLY LEARNED IS IS NOT ONLY AL
OLECKO WHATEVER AMOUNTS TO
SAYING IT'S FINDING QUALIFIED
FOLKS.
ESPECIALLY IN MY PART OF THE
STATE.
TO BE ABLE TO HIRE THOSE
QUALIFIED FOLKS AND THEN. PAY
THEM WHAT THEY ARE.
ENTITLED TO.
AND THEN ALSO TO THE POINT OF
ISOLATION WE ARE SUCH A LARGE
GEOGRAPHY AND SO AGAIN FOR THE
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE ON THE VERGE
OF BEING. PUT INTO SKILLED
NURSING OR SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
FOLKS THAT ARE GOING OUT
SOMETIMES ONLY ONCE A YEAR IN
SOME CASES TWICE A YEAR.
THEY MIGHT BE THE ONLY
INTERACTION AGAIN YOU KNOW IN
THEIR HOME BECAUSE THERE'S TOO
FAR OUT TO EVEN GET HOME
DELIVERED MEALS SO JUST GOING
OUT ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR TO SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING A CHECKING
ACCOUNT CARE COORDINATION IS
ESSENTIAL. MY LAST POINT IS
BECAUSE AGAIN IN A RURAL AREA WE
DON'T HAVE MANY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AT ALL. AND WHAT ONES
WE DO HAVE ARE ABOUT NINETY
PERCENT OF CAPACITY AND THAT'S
WHAT TRACY BARBARA BEHIND ME IS
GOING TO ADDRESS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
A LOT ABOUT ADDRESSING THAT BUT.
TRACY BARBARA PROGRAM MANAGER
THE OMBUDSMAN SERVICES AND
LASSEN MODOC SHASTA SECURE
TRINITY COUNTIES. AND.
AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER AND A
SENIOR.
PROVIDER I CAN RESPECT THE
PLIGHT OF THE PROGRAM AND THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE NO. NO LONG
TERM BEDS WE DON'T HAVE
AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING WE
DON'T HAVE WE DON'T HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE ASSISTED LIVING
THAT OUR SENIORS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD THE CRUISE SHIP ASSISTED
LIVING SAY WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
LOWER RATES OF PACING LIVINGS
ANYMORE PALM. SO I CAN I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE PLIGHT AND I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE REQUEST
THANK YOU.
HOME.
AND EVERY PUMP.
I CAN'T SPEAK VERY WELL PHIL
TRESSES GREATLY PARTLY THAT YOU.
ALRIGHT SOMEONE READ SOMETHING
THE BEVERLY WROTE FOR US.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS BEVERLY PUMP BUT DUE
TO HEALTH ISSUES TREES O'DONNELL
SPEAK FROM TODAY.
UPON MOVING TO SACRAMENTO FROM
WISCONSIN EIGHT YEARS AGO I WAS
WELCOMED BY THERESA HOGAN OF THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM.
TREES ARE REVIEWED MY HOME FOR
SAFETY CONCERNS AND SOON IN
MISSISSIPPI PROVIDED ME WITH
GRAB BARS.
A WEEK FREE FAUCETS AND REPLACED
BAD FLOORING.
IN MY BATHROOM
THUS GIVING ME BETTER LIVING
CONDITIONS AND SAFETY.
OVER TIME I GAS STOVE TOP WAS
REPLACED SO MY HOME WERE NOT A
BLOW UP.
SEEMS FAIR TO.
AS MY HEALTH WORSENED AND STEPS
WERE UNMANAGEABLE IN MISSISSIPPI
INSTALLED AN ELECTRIC LIVE TO MY
PORCH
SO I CAN STAY IN MY BELOVED
HOME.
AT THIS TIME THEY ALSO FURNISHED
A COMFY.
M. MEMORY FOAM PAD FOR MY
HOSPITAL BED.
THIS GREAT AGENCY PROVIDES MY
TRANSPORTATION TO MEDICAL AND
SOCIAL EVENTS AS WELL AS FOR MY
RIGHT HERE TODAY. WITH THE
MISSISSIPPI IN MY LIFE. I WILL
NOT SIT ON DISPLAY IN THE
HALLWAY OF A NURSING HOME BUT
WILL INSTEAD.
WAVE TO YOU FROM MY FRONT PORCH
AS YOU DRIVE BY.
I'D LOVE.
WE SENIOR CITIZENS AND DISABLED
WANT TO STAY IN OUR HOMES TO
ENJOY OUR REMAINING YEARS WE ALL
NEED YOUR HELP.
PLEASE VOTE FAVORABLY ON IN
MISSISSIPPI LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU THINK ABOUT HER.
AND IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND ALSO SPEAK.
AS A SITE DIRECTOR FOR TWO
SITES.
SERVING SACRAMENTO PLASTER YOLO
AND YUBA COUNTIES.
.
AND WHAT I'M WOULD ASK YOU TO DO
AT BEVERLY WAS ABLE TO MAKE IT
TODAY BUT NOT MAYOR VERY MANY OF
OUR PARTICIPANTS ARE AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT IT WAS A CHALLENGE. FOR
HER TO MAKE IT. IMAGINE THIS
ROOM FILLED FOUR AND A HALF
TIMES OVER WHICH JUST OUR SITES
PARTICIPANTS.
BEING HERE.
AND THAT'S WHO. I REPRESENT
TODAY AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE.
REALLY TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THIS REQUEST FOR INCREASED
FUNDING IN ORDER TO KEEP
SERVICES ALIVE FOR PEOPLE LIKE
BEVERLY GETS.
AND HUMAN.
HI MY NAME IS JESSE WILLIAMS AND
I AM THE ASSISTANCE I DIRECTOR
OUTPUT IN MISSISSIPPI SERVICE
SACRAMENTO YELLOW PLASTER AND
YUBA COUNTIES. I'M A READER ARM
PERSONAL STORY ABOUT ONE OF OUR.
CLIENTS AND ONE OF OUR STAFF
MEMBERS.
I PERSONALLY WITNESSED ONE OF
OUR OF SOULS WERE CARE MANAGERS
ARE AFFECTED EFFECTIVENESS WITH
EIGHTY THREE OH. MAIL CLIENT
WHAT ACT OF SUICIDE IDEATION AND
AT TEN DURING A HOME VISIT THAT
COPY HER ALL.
THIS IS THE MAN WHO WORKS
EXPERIENCE MUCH TRAUMA AND PAIN
DURING HIS CHILDHOOD. THEM MST
PEOPLE EVER WILL AND FIVE LIFE
TIME.
HIS LEVEL OF MISTRUST FOR OTHERS
IS EXTREMELY HIGH AND HE HAS A
HISTORY OF DECLINING SERVICES
ARE. PROVIDED AT THE DOOR.
HIS APARTMENT HAD NARROW AND
CROWDED PATHWAYS DUE TO HIS
SENATE SEAT OR ITEMS TISSUES AND
OTHER TRASH LITTERED THE FLOOR.
WHERE HE HAD BEEN AT THE ONE
THING'S FOR WHAT APPEARED TO
HAVE BEEN WEEKS?
HIS APARTMENT HAVE STRONG ODORS
OF URINE AND ROTTING FULL AND
TRASH AND HIS REFRIGERATOR HAD
THE SMELL OF ROTTING FOOD. THAT
WAS OVERWHELMING S..
AS WHERE THE NUMBER OF SMALL
FAST NOTED IN AND AROUND THE
REFRIGERATORS.
HIS BELOVED BAR WAS IN THE HOME
AND SHE WAS HIS PRIMARY CONCERN.
FRANCIS FRANCISCO ALSO HAVE FOR
PLASTIC GROCERY BAGS FULL OF
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS THAT HE
HAD NOT BEEN TAKING INCLUDING
MEDICATIONS FOR DEPRESSION.
DIABETES AND NARCOTIC PAIN
MEDICATION.
WHEN OUR COURAGE TO HAND THE
BACKS OF MEDICATION TO.
MS AS P. ARM STAFF WHAT
DISPOSAL HE DECLINED INDICATED
THAT THIS WAS HIS PLAN FOR
ENDING HIS LIFE. WHEN HE HAD
MADE THAT CHOICE.
I WITNESS M. F. THAT P. STAFF
COMPASSIONATELY CONNECT WHAT ON
THE CLIENT INFORM HIM THAT SHE
DID NOT WANT HIM TO COMMIT
SUICIDE. AND THAT SHE WOULD BE
SAID IF YOU MADE THAT CHOICE
GIVING HIM A HOT.
HE AGREED TO CONTRACT WITH HER
NOT TO MAKE ANY SWELLED SILENT
GESTURES FOR ONE WEEK AND TO
CALL HER IF HE WAS CONSIDERING
SUICIDE.
THOUGH HE CONTINUED TO STRUGGLE
WITH DEPRESSION AND SUICIDE
IDEATION NSF PIECE STAFF HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BILL AND UPPER PORT
ANGELES WOULD. WITH THIS CLIENT
TO HELP KEEP HIM LIVING SAFELY
IN HIS HOME FOR OVER THE THREE
YEARS SHE HAD BEEN WORKING WITH
HIM.
AND THOUGH THE SUCCESS THINGS
INTO IT INCREMENTAL THEY HAVE
BEEN HUGE.
THIS REALLY SAW THE POWER AN SS
P. CARE MARRIAGES APPROACH THAT
WORKS WITH ALL OF OUR LOW INCOME
FREELANCING USED TO STAND AT
HOME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
DOCTOR BY REPORTERS SITE
DIRECTOR FOR IN MISSISSIPPI
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
I'VE BEEN LISTENING OUTSIDE AND
HEARING STORIES HERE I DON'T
ENVY YOU. IN OTHER WORDS YOU
HAVE SO MANY MOUTHS TO FEED SO
MANY PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORTHY
BEYOND EVEN SPEAKING ABOUT. THE
ANECDOTAL STORIES GO ON AND ON
AND ON I HAD TWO OR THREE
PREPARED FOR YOU BUT I WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH ONE ONE IN
PARTICULAR STORY.
ONE OF THIS IN ONE OF OUR
PARTICULAR CLIENTS.
IS A DIALYSIS PRODUCE.
AND IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOR
WHATEVER REASON THERE'S NO
TRANSPORTATION BY THE DIALYSIS
CLINICS TO GET TO AND FROM. YOU
WERE ASKING EARLIER WHAT WILL BE
THE EFFECT IF WE DON'T GET THAT
FUNDING. ONE OF THE ISSUES IS
THIS LADY GOES THREE TIMES A
WEEK FOR WEEKS A MONTH.
THAT COSTS NOW IS ALMOST A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH IN THAT
TRANSPORTATION WEARS TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THAT COST WAS
MAYBE AROUND A HUNDRED. SO THE
INCREASE IN TERMS OF COSTING OF
PARROTING THE KIND OF LIFE AND
DEATH CARE.
IT'S LIFE AND DEATH THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I WOULD BEG YOU
REALLY AND TRULY I'M AT THE AGE
NOW WHERE I CAN BAG IT DOESN'T
BOTHER ME AT ALL. OF DISLIKE
WEARING PURPLE IN DYING YOUR
HAIR AFTER GETS GREAT SO ONE OF
THE THINGS I WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THIS THE THOUGHT THAT.
BECAUSE ELEMENT WE SAVE MONEY.
I WAS NEVER GREAT MATH THAT'S
WHY I BECAME A PSYCHOLOGIST SO
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MY MY
THAT I'VE LEARNED ABOUT.
THE PROGRAM FINANCIALLY IS THAT
BOTH FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO TAKE CARE OF IN A
MISSISSIPPI PERSON.
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
TO PUT THEM IN A SKILLED NURSING
SOCIETY NOW I MAY NOT BE REALLY
SMART BUT FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE WHAT THE
POINT I WAS GETTING AND I WANNA
LEAVE YOU WITH ONE LAST THOUGHT.
CARE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE CARED FOR UPS.
IS ONE OF OUR HIGHEST HONORS
LET'S ALL BE HONORABLE THANK
YOU.
KIM.
NANCY MERGED WITH THE CONGRESS
OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND WE ARE
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET REQUEST.
FOR ALL OF THE REASONS AND ALL
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE SHARED
STORIES. AND DOVE STATISTICS AND
ALL OF THAT WE WE RECOGNIZE THIS
PROGRAM IS FAR MORE VALUABLE
THAN ITS LINE ITEM IN THE
BUDGET.
YOU CAN'T COMMIT.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST TO HAVE
NOTHING TO HAD THANK YOU.
A RIGID STRANGE FROM THE OF
EMESIS BESIDE DIRECTOR FOR NAPA
AND SOLANO COUNTIES.
AND. I EXPECT THAT MY SITE WILL
CLOSE IF WE DON'T. GET SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
A EMESIS PIECE OF SORT OF BEEN
GETTING IT FROM ALL SIDES FOR
AWHILE NOW.
A IT'S BECOMING CREASING LEE
DIFFICULT TO HIRE QUALIFIED
STAFF.
THERE ACUITY LEVEL OF THE
CLIENTS THAT PARTICIPANTS LA
WHERE ROLLING IS HIGHER.
WAS SEEING.
MORE MORE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH THAT.
ARE.
VERY TIME CONSUMING AND.
REQUIRE LEVEL OF EXPERTISE THAT
THAT WAS REALLY CHALLENGING FOR
A LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS.
SO.
WE WE.
WHEN EMESIS PLEASE GO AWAY OR
WHEN THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES ROLLING OVER FROM ONE
SITE TO ANOTHER. IT IMPACTS LOTS
OF OTHER PROGRAMS TO BECAUSE
EMESIS P..
DOES MORE THAN JUST WHAT OUR
PROGRAM DOES WE CONNECT HOW
PARTICIPANTS WITH AYE CHESS
ASKS.
WE RESOLVE ISSUES WITH
RESURFACED HAITIANS WITH I JUST
ASKED WE RESOLVE ISSUES BETWEEN.
OPTUS A PRINCE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS TO TRY TO KEEP SOME
STABILITY THERE AS THE
AVAILABILITY OF CARE GIVERS GOES
DOWN AND.
WITHIN OUR COUNTIES AT LEAST.
.
ALSO CONNECT PEOPLE WITH MEALS
ON WHEELS LEGAL SERVICES AND ALL
KINDS OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING IN THE COMMUNITY.
SAW EMESIS PETE THEY'LL SERVE
SUCH A A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE.
ALSO.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES FOR
MISSISSIPPI IS WE CAN'T JUST
MAKE MORE MONEY BY SERVING MORE
PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T SAVE MONEY BY HIRING
LESS STAFF WE HAVE RATIOS THAT
WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN BETWEEN US
THE STAFFING. AND THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS THAT WHERE.
SERVING.
AND WHAT WE CAN DRAW DOWN MORE
THAN A HUNDRED PERCENT OF OUR
CONTRACT BY SERVING MORE PEOPLE.
WE SERVE LESS PEOPLE WE DRAW
DOWN LESS FUNDING SO JUST AS A
BUSINESS MODEL IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. A TO OPERATE A IN THE
FACE OF EVER RISING COSTS
FOR REALLY FOR EVERYTHING THAT
IT TAKES TO DO BUSINESS THE
INSURANCE KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON
HIRING STAFF.
A.
EVERYTHING MILEAGE ALL THAT MUCH
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD TODAY SUB
THANK YOU I HOPE YOU ARE.
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER ON SUPPORTING
THIS.
NATIONAL FUNDING THAT YOU THINK
IS OUR.
STEVE A GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF THAT
ADAM AND MATHIS PMSA BUDGET
PROPOSAL OF FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND JUST ECHO
OUR PREVIOUS ONGOING CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT I MUST AYE MATHIS P.
INTEGRATION INTO CC I.
HUMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE SOME OF SOME A POLICY
ANALYST WITH ULTIMATE HEALTH
SERVICES.
WE'RE THE LARGEST FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CURRENTLY
SERVE.
BUT NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AND WE'RE
ALSO NEMESIS BE PROVIDED WE
PROVIDE OF THIS WOULD PROVIDE A
MISSISSIPPI SERVICES.
TWO FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
CLIENTS AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE BUDGET
OF THE RECESSION ERA BUDGET CUTS
WE HAVE HAD TO LET GO OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO CLIENTS WHICH
REPRESENTS A TWENTY PERCENT
DECLINE.
AND ALSO THEY GOT MANY OTHER
CENTERS.
WE ARE HAVING TO RELY ON
ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF FUNDING.
OH I ECHO WHAT OTHER ANSWER
OTHERS HAVE SAID AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
REQUEST THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EDDIE
SELECT GONE AND I'M
REPRESENTING.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SOURCE WIVES
MSO SPEYSIDE SERBIAN THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
CLIENTS.
I THAT THEY ARE THEY ARE YET
THAT WE SERVE IT'S VERY A ROUTE
SOME AREAS ARE VERY RURAL OTHER
AREAS ARE VERY URBAN. SOUL IT'S
THE A MIXTURE OF VERY DIVERSE.
PARTICIPANTS
I I ECHO WHAT. ALL OF MY PEERS
HAVE SAID ABOUT SOUGHT THE
DIFFICULTIES RUNNING THE PROGRAM
STOP BUDGETARY WYETH'S.
ARE WE CURRENTLY. UNDER AFTER
SUBSIDIZING THE PROGRAM BY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
OR STAFF IT'S UNDERPAID UP BY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF WHAT THE
GOING RATES AVERAGE RATE FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AREA. AND.
THAT LASTS
SEVEN MONTHS I'VE PLOTS FOR A.
UP VERY WELL QUALIFIED SOCIAL
WORKERS AND HAVE TO HIRE. VERY.
IN EXPERIENCE NEW SOCIAL
WORKERS TO FILL THE POSITIONS
BECAUSE OUR SALARIES ARE NOT
COMPETITIVE TO. THE GOING RATE
SO ISTRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
ALIMENTATION OF FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THINKING.
QUICKLY KITANA SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION ALAMEDA COUNTY A WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE REQUEST.
FOR THE ARE FUNDING FOR MS SP.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO OUR REQUESTS
THAT TO A BEHALF OF THE OLDER
ADULTS.
THAT.
WE.
THINK ABOUT THIS IS A
PARTNERSHIP.
AND OUR OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT THE LIVES.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. WANTING
TO LIVE IN DIGNITY AND SAFETY.
AND HOLY.
AS MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU.
GIVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CAL COLOR.
ONE OF THE TENETS OF THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS TO ASSIST
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THE LEAST
I WE CAN DO ALL THAT THE
ADVOCATING FOR THE RESIDENTES
FATHER IN THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY.
BUT IF THERE ISN'T A PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THEM UPON LEAVING
THEY'RE JUST GONNA END UP BACK
IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE BACK IN THAT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
SO BECAUSE WE LOOK AT THIS IS A
WORK DETERRENT FOREST'S ONE.
BUT MORE.
IF THE DIGNITY ISSUE ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT. AND
ALSO A COST SAVER TO THE STATE.
PLEASE SUPPORT
I COMMEND.
INTEREST THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN OF OURS BUT THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AS
YOU'VE HEARD AND MISSISSIPPI
CLIENTS ARE.
HAVE VERY COMPLEX CONDITIONS
ARM THEIR IMPAIRED AND A
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS. WE SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST
WE CAME.
JOHN POINTER CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
WHAT OUR PERSONAL LIVES ALL THE
ISSUES RAISED TODAY IN MY
OPINION IS THAT THE INVOLVE OUR
PARENTS?
OUR GRANDPARENTS
SIBLINGS A CIRCLE OF FRIENDS.
I URGE YOU TO WATCH INCREASE THE
PROGRAM FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
ISSUE FOR I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS MANY COMMENTS WE MAY
HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO FOGLIGHTS
IS.
WHAT ELSE CAN WE SAY WE AGREE
WITH THE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
HAS BEEN SAID IT'S AND I
PARTICULARLY AGREE WITH THE FACT
THAT WE CAN SAVE MONEY? ON BY
DOING THIS IN THE FRONT AND AND
AND UNFORTUNATELY. THE IT SUCH
THAT ONE WERE NEGOTIATING.
WE CAN'T SHOW. YOU KNOW IT
ACTUAL SAVINGS AND AND SO WE YOU
KNOW ARE COMMITTED TO TRYING TO
GET WHATEVER WE CAN FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO OBVIOUSLY YOU.
CAN A MAN AS YOU CAN IMAGINE DR
ARAMBULA FROM FORMER.
.
MEDICAL OF.
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR AND I'M A
FORMER TEACHER AND SO IT'S IN
OUR NATURE AND IT'S IN OUR. OF
PREVIOUS EXPERIENCES THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LACK OF
RESOURCES. AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO. AUGUST
TO GET THE RESOURCES AND THE
FRONT END SO THAT WE DON'T PAY
IT AT THE BACK AND AND THAT'S
TRUE IN EMERGENCY ROOMS IT'S
DRAWN SCHOOLS AND CLASSROOMS
AND.
SO KNOW THAT WE WILL GO IN THERE
FIGHTING FOR THIS.
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T MAKE ANY
PROMISES AS TO WHAT THE RESULT
WILL BE BUT WE CAN WE CAN I
LEAST I CAN PROMISE THAT WE WILL
FIGHT TO GET WHATEVER WE CAN.
I'M FOR THE SERVICES AND IT'S.
I IT'S BEEN THIS IS MY SECOND
YEAR AND JUST LISTENING TO THE
STORIES.
.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING IT'S
HEARTBREAKING BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT SOMEBODY MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF MOUTHS TO
FEED BUT. I THINK IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO FEED THOSE THOSE
MOUTHS AND SO I THINK WE'RE
COMMITTED APPEAR TO. DOING WHAT
WE CAN FOR FOR FOR ALL THE
PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE ALL WHERE
THE PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
MY FIRST QUESTIONS CAN BE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I'M INTERESTED IN HOW.
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE MS SP FOUR
CONSUMERS WILL BE AFFECTED IN
THE TRANSITION.
CAN YOU PLEASE TELL US ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU ENVISION.
ON THE CHARACTER OF CARE MODEL
ON.
HOW YOUR TRANSITION PLAN FOSTERS
THAT?
CERTAINLY AND I THINK THEY'RE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS THAT YOU'VE
ASKED ABOUT THEIR FIRST OF ALL
WITH RESPECT TO.
WHAT THE CARE MODEL WILL LOOK
LIKE WE ACTUALLY ARE ENGAGING IN
A MODEL OF CARE WORK GROUP RIGHT
NOW THAT'S A PART OF THE
MISSISSIPPI TRANSITION WORK
GROUP? ON THAT WE ARE ENGAGING
IN WHAT THE DEPARTMENT ANY OF
AGING AND WITH THEM ASSIST PIECE
ITEM WITH MSA AND SO I DON'T
WANT TO GET OUT TOO FAR IN FRONT
OF MYSELF IN TERMS OF SPEAKING
TO WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE. AND
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT. AND WHAT WILL THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE INDIVIDUAL BE
EYES THEY ARE IN BOLD OR.
AS THEY BECOME A PART OF THE
AYE MISSISSIPPI PROGRAM POST THE
TRANSITION LOOKING AT WHAT THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS WOULD LOOK
LIKE. I'M AND SO REALLY THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD SAY RIGHT NOW WITH
RESPECT THE MODEL OF CARE. I'M
IN TERMS OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
WITH.
BENEFICIARIES THAT WOULD BE
TRANSITIONING SPECIFICALLY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ISSUED GUIDANCE I
THAT WE CALL OUR GRANDFATHER
POPULATION SO ESSENTIALLY
BENEFICIARIES WILL CONTINUE TO
WREAK MAIN.
AND WITH THEIR SAME SERVICES AS
LONG AS THEY'RE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SERVICES FOR THEM FOR
UP TO TWELVE MONTHS ON POST
TRANSITION AND FOLLOWING THAT
OUR HEALTH PLANS WOULD WORK
CLOSELY WITH THOSE BENEFICIARIES
TO.
ASSESS THEM AND DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE WITH THOSE SERVICES OR
WHETHER OR NOT THERE CARE PLAN
WHICH CHANGE.
GOOD.
FOR THE ADVOCATES ON THE RATE
INCREASE YOUR SEEKING.
CAN YOU TELL US HOW IT WILL WORK
FOR THE COUNTIES WHERE AN SS P.
IS TRANSITIONING.
AND WHERE IN MISSISSIPPI IS NOT
AFFECTED BY THE TRANSITION SO IT
BECAUSE.
AND THAT IS IT A DISCUSSION
THAT OBVIOUSLY IT WAS KIND OF
ABOVE US IN TERMS OF HOW DOES
THAT MECHANISM WORK IN TERMS OF
THE WITH THE MONEY THAT FLOWS
FROM THE STATE TO THE HEALTH
PLANS. WHO IN THE TRANSITION
COUNTIES ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
PAIN MSP DIRECTLY NOW?
I'M I THINK BUT FOR ME THE
BIGGEST THING IS TO KEEP IN MIND
IS WE'RE STILL NOT THERE FOR
TRANSITION WERE BLEEDING NOW.
AND WE'RE AND THE RATE THAT WERE
BEING PAID IS THE EXACT SAME
RATE TO THAT IF YOU ARE A IF IT
WAS IT WAS IT WAS DONE ON A RATE
STRUCTURE BASSIST AND WAS A
SIMPLE MATH EQUATION TAKING THE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS. DIVIDED BY
SLOTS KIND OF THING SO IT WOULD
WORK AT THE SAME RATE EVERYWHERE
SO ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW THE
MECHANISM THE STATE WOULD USE.
TO GET THAT MONEY DOWN TO US
WERE ALL STILL BE PAYMENT PAYING
RIGHT NOW AND UNTIL AND THERE'S
WE WE'RE NOT IT TRANSITION YET
THE EXACT SAME THING AND NEEDING
TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN. BUT
HEALTH BUT DOESN'T SPEAK TO NON.
I THINK I WOULD ECHO MARCH
CONNELLY REFERENCE THAT.
SO MUCH FOCUS AROUND IN
MISSISSIPPI OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS HAVE BEEN RELATED TO THE
TRACK TRANSITION WITH CCI. AND
THAT IN THAT NON TO SEE I
COUNTIES AND ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT TODAY ARE
STILL VERY REAL AND SO. WHILE
THERE ISN'T.
A PLAN THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT
WOULD. IMPACT THE TRANSITION OF
CARE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THE THE
FUNDING AUGMENTATION REQUEST IS.
AS MUCH A A PRIORITY AND AND
NEED FOR THE NONCE HE SAID I
COUNTIES IT'S CITIZENS TO TRY
COUNTIES THAT. IN SOME WAYS
ARGUABLY EVEN MORE BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT THERE'S LACK OF
CLARITY AS TO WHAT. THINGS WILL
LOOK LIKE IN THE ANTI CHECKOUT
IS BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
ISSUE FOR OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
TUITION FIVE THANK YOU FOR THIS
PANEL
.
I THINK WE'LL START WITH SUSAN
AND GO TO STELLAR IF THAT'S
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND DIRECTOR CALMLY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING THIS ITEM ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF WORK ON
ON THIS. AM THE ANALYSIS
DESCRIBES WHAT THE CONCEPT IS WE
WANT TO ESTABLISH A BASELINE OF
DEMENTIA CAPABLE AND COMPETENT
STAFF. IN ALL THIRTY THREE AREA
AGENCY. ON AGING IN OUR STATE.
ON THIS IS A ONE TIME FUNDING
REQUEST.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE STAFF CAN BE BROUGHT UP TO
SPEED AND WE CAN ESTABLISH THAT
BASELINE OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD.
SO THAT ALL STAFF WILL BE
TRAINED THEY'LL HAVE THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AND
IMPORTANTLY THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
REFER INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
THAT WOULD BE ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
MEMORY.
AS WELL AS CARE GIVERS TO THE
RISK TO THE APPROPRIATE AND
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
SOME THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM
TODAY AS WELL AS THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS IN THE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE CENTERS IN
OUR STATE.
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU.
WE HAD A REPORT ISSUED
YESTERDAY THAT WAS SHARED WITH
ALL OF YOUR OFFICES BET ON THE
CHAIR IN PARTICULAR MAY BE
INTERESTED TO KNOW THAT.
IN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
DOWNSTREAM AND UPSTREAM IN THE
BENEFITS OF EARLY DETECTION.
CERTAINLY ARE TO.
EQUIP INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
TO AVOID MUCH OF WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN HEARING IN THIS HEARING ON
SO THAT WE CAN BE MORE
PROACTIVE.
AND PLAN FOR HEALTHCARE.
NEEDS.
OF ONE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS.
WE HAD WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
WE HAD ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOR EVERYONE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE
WE HAD ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS.
AND TODAY IN THIS COMMITTEE OR
NOT TALKING ABOUT.
HEALTH CARE UTILIZATION ON THE
MEDI CAL SIDE I'M ESPECIALLY
WITH HOSPITALIZATIONS.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT EARLY
DETECTION WE HOPE ON WITH THIS
CAMPAIGN THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
DIAGNOSED EARLIER THEY CAN GET
CONNECTED TO FREE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES. ON THEY CAN EXERCISE
THEIR HEALTH LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL.
DIRECTIVES.
THE REPORT THAT WAS ISSUED
YESTERDAY THAT WAS SHARED WITH
YOUR OFFICES INDICATES THAT
EARLY DETECTION AND DIAGNOSIS
NATIONWIDE. CAN SAVE OUR COUNTRY
SEVEN POINT NINE TRILLION
DOLLARS IF WE GET THIS RIGHT.
ON CALIFORNIA'S IS ONE OF FIFTY
STATES.
LESS THAN HALF OF PEOPLE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH THAT DIAGNOSIS DOCUMENTED
IN THEIR MEDICAL RECORD THAT'S A
NATIONWIDE STATISTIC. ON BUT WE
HAVE THE LARGEST POPULATION IN
THE COUNTRY HERE SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
I AM I WANTED TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUE AND I DON'T WANNA TALK
ANY FURTHER BUT STELLA DE LA
PENA.
WORKS FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION AND SHE SERVES.
AS OUR REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CHAPTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ALL OF YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
PLAN TO SHARE SOME INFORMATION
AND TODAY WITH YOU AND I
ACTUALLY HAVE NOT COME ALONE SO
AND I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU TO.
MY FATHER WHO. I THINK WAS VERY
ATTRACTIVE. AND ANYONE TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIM AND MY
FATHER AND DIED FROM ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT.
HE WAS EIGHTY THREE YEARS OLD AT
THE TIME WE LEARNED ABOUT HIS
DISEASE SHORTLY AFTER A CRISIS
WHEN HE WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM US.
AND HE WAS TAKEN FROM US BY THE
POLICE BY OUR LOCAL POLICE AND
EVER ALLOWED TO RETURN HOME
AGAIN.
MY DAD HAD PROBLEMS WITH MEMORY
AND JUDGMENT FIVE YEARS PRIOR.
HE HAD BECOME LOST FREQUENTLY
AND HE HALLUCINATED. AND FOR
YEARS AND REGULAR VISITS TO OUR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS THE USUALLY
RESULTED IN COMMENTS ABOUT
BOLDLY.
AND VERY MINIMAL SUPPORT AND
EDUCATION.
ON THE DAY OF OF THE CRISIS MY
SISTER WAS DRIVING HIM TO
ETERNAL APPOINTMENT THEY STOPPED
AT A RAILROAD CROSSING. AND THE
NOISE OF THE TRAINS STARTLED
HIM.
HE BECAME AGITATED UNWANTED EXIT
THE DOOR.
MY SISTER TRIED TO RESTRAIN HIM
FROM LEAVING THE CAR AND HE
BEGAN TO HIT HER.
A POLICE OFFICER ALSO STOPPED AT
THE RAILROAD CROSSING.
SAW MY FATHER HITTING MY SISTER.
SO HE APPROACHED THE CAR QUICKLY
AND.
HE REMOVED MY FATHER THREW HIM
AGAINST THE CAR AND HANDCUFFED
HIM.
MY SISTER TRIED TO INTERVENE AND
TOLD THE OFFICER.
SEC
SCARED.
AND THE OFFICERS REPLY WAS.
I AM TAKING THEM.
IN OR I AM TAKING THEM TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM YOU CHOOSE.
AND SO HE WAS TAKEN TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
AFTER THREE DAYS IN THE HOSPITAL
AFTER NUMEROUS TESTS.
WE WERE TOLD THAT HE HAD
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
HE WAS THEN DISCHARGED TO A
FIFTY BAD ASSISTED LIVING
COMMUNITY THAT AT THE TIME ONLY
HAD TWO STAFF MEMBERS.
WHO HAD BEEN TRAINED TO ASSIST
PATIENTS WITH MEMORY?
AND ISSUES.
MY FATHER LIVED TWO YEARS IN THE
COMMUNITY BEFORE HE DIED.
HE DECLINED VERY QUICKLY THE
FIRST YEAR.
LOS TOP OF ITS WAY AND IN THE
LAST YEAR HE DIDN'T KNOW HIS
FAMILY.
THIS DEVASTATED OUR FAMILY
IMMENSELY MY MOTHER IN THAT TIME
HAD TWO STROKES.
OUR LIVES WERE TURNED COMPLETELY
UPSIDE DOWN TRYING TO BE
INVOLVED. IN HIS LIFE AND IN HIS
NEW CARE SETTING.
TO THIS DAY I BELIEVE IN MY
HEART.
THAT.
OUR DADS QUALITY OF LIFE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE LENGTH
OF HIS LIFE. AND THE QUALITY OF
OUR LIVES
COULD HAVE BEEN VERY DIFFERENT
IN THOSE FIVE YEARS HAD WE
KNOWN.
ABOUT ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
AND HAD A BETTER SUPPORT HIS
DISEASE PROCESS AT HOME.
EVEN HOW TO ADD TO THE
ENRICHMENT OF HIS VERY FINAL
YEARS IN THE COMMUNITY HOME.
MAINTAINING HIS DIGNITY WHICH
WAS SO IMPORTANT TO HIM.
MY MOM IS NOW IN THE EARLIER
STAGES OF DEMENTIA.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW.
ABOUT ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE THIS
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN VERY
DIFFERENT FOR OUR FAMILY.
WE ARE PREPARING NOW FOR WHAT WE
KNOW WILL COME.
I FEAR TO. THAT I WILL GET THIS
DISEASE AND I WANT MY CHILDREN
TO BE INFORMED.
AM PREPARED.
I HAVE A FAMILY HISTORY OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
I'VE HAD A STROKE I'VE HAD A
BRAIN INJURY.
I AM A WOMAN. AND I AM LATINA.
ALL OF THESE THINGS INCREASE MY
WRISTS FOR GETTING THIS DISEASE
AND I AM SCARED.
IN MY WORK IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
I SEE THE DIFFERENCE ON A DAILY
BASIS THE FAMILIES WHO WALKIN.
IN CRISIS I SEE THEM BROKEN AND
LOST JUST LIKE MY FAMILY ROOTS.
AND I SEE THE TIME THAT IT TAKES
TO GET THEM TO BEGIN TO RECOVER
FROM THE IMPACT.
SOME NEVER DO.
THE ROAD IS LONG AND IT'S HARD.
SPENCER.
MANY WITH INCREASED HEALTH
ISSUES OF THEIR OWN BECAUSE OF
THE DEMANDS OF CAREGIVING TO DO
THEIR VERY FAST.
ALMOST ALWAYS.
I HERE OUR STAFF HERE'S I WISH I
WOULD HAVE KNOWN ABOUT YOU I
WISH I WOULD HAVE KNOWN ABOUT
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
I WOULD IT WOULD HAVE BEEN SO
DIFFERENT.
AND I SEE THE DIFFERENCE THE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
FAMILIES WHO COME MEAN EVEN WITH
VERY BASIC KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
DISEASE.
AND WHAT IT MAKES.
WHAT DIFFERENCE IT MAKES IN
THEIR OWN LIVES AND IN THEIR
FAMILY'S LIVES?
IN THEIR HOPE AN INTER DESIRE TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE DISEASE AND
HOW THEY CAN BETTER SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER AND THEIR
LOVED ONE.
THEY ARE PROACTIVE IN THEIR
LOVED ONES CARE THEY ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES THEY
PREPARE THE ATTEND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS TO LEARN TO BE BETTER
CARE GIVERS.
AND THE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
IN THE PROCESS THEY ALSO LEARN
HOW TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
AND THIS GREATLY IMPACTS THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF EVERYONE
INVOLVED.
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY MY DAD IS
NO LONGER WITH US.
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
INCREASE EDUCATION ABOUT
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE DESPERATELY NEED
AT.
THERE'S TOO MUCH DEVASTATION
ACCOUNT BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
AWARENESS
MY STORY I I WOULD LOVE TO TELL
YOU THAT IT IS. A VERY UNUSUAL
STORY.
IT IT'S NOT WE HEAR CRISIS
EVERYDAY ON FROM FAMILIES THAT
WALKING TO OUR OFFICE.
AND WE HEAR THEM TOO OFTEN AND
TOO MANY.
SO I AM HERE TO PASS AND AND I
BELIEVE THERE WAS SANDBAGGING
EARLIER SO I AM WILLING TO BACK
MYSELF.
INTO BAG THAT YOU THAT YOU
CONSIDER
SUPPORTING.
OUR REQUEST
FOR FUNDING.
BIGGEST VILLAIN SUSAN DIRECTOR
CALMLY.
S. LIKE THAT I THINK THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION HAS
REALLY SPOKEN QUITE ELOQUENTLY
TO THE ON. THE POPULATION
IMPACTS BOTH IN TERMS OF
INDIVIDUALS DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
ON I'M HAVING A LITTLE HARD TIME
HER MYSELF MY DAD WOULD UP IN
NINETY SEVEN. THIS WEEK AND.
AFTER A STROKE I HAD HAD.
DEVELOPED ALZHEIMER'S.
ON AND WE CARE FOR HIM WERE ABLE
TO CARE FOR HIM AT HOME FOR FIVE
YEARS AND IT'S KIND OF ONE OF
THOSE WEEKS.
AT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
CERTAINLY IMPACTS ALL FAMILIES I
THINK THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A JUST IN TERMS OF REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL I KNOW IT'S INTENDED TO
BE A ONE TIME ONLY IN TERMS OF
AND THE FUNDING. ON WITH A TWO
YEAR TIME TIMEFRAME. ON THERE
ARE STILL. LOTS I THINK IN TERMS
OF MOVING PARTS IN THE PROPOSAL.
ON MY JUST BASIC KIND OF LOOKING
AT FROM AN OPERATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE SEEMS TIMING WISE
ANGER TALK ABOUT CONTRACTING AND
OTHER. PROPHECIES AND AT AN
EARLIER SEGMENT PROBABLY CLOSER
TO TWO AND A HALF TO THREE YEARS
JUST IN TERMS OF. SOME OF THOSE
PIECES ARMED TO THE PROPOSAL BUT
I'M CERTAINLY WILLING TO VERY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND PARTLY TO
FINANCE AND. THE ADVOCATES IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THIS WEEK.
LL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WELL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
ISSUE FIVE.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN GERALD
KELCH.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF AREA AGENCIES ON AGING. WE'RE
EXCITED TO BE WORKING WITH
IMPARTING WITH ALZHEIMER'S
CALIFORNIA ON THIS BUDGET
REQUEST.
YOU KNOW THE ME SHARE THAT
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE
HAS ONE OF THE CORD MANDATES
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
HEAD OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
WERE NO TO SEE.
THAT MORE AND MORE CALLS TO OUR
HANEY PROGRAMS
HAS TO DO WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
IT'S SOMETHING NOW LIKE FORTY
PERCENT OF THE BECAUSE OF WHERE
RECEIVING.
A ON THESE A CUP ON THESE
TELEPHONE CALLS A HAS TO DO WITH
ALZHEIMER'S.
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE USED HIS IS
A NATURAL ALLIANCE BETWEEN THE
ALZHEIMER'S OR ORGANIZATIONS AND
AN AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
WHAT IT DOES IS BRING THE
STRENGTHS OF BOTH COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER?
HA HA OUR NETWORK IN TERMS OF OF
OUT REACH.
TO THE COMMUNITY THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GET THESE PHONE CALLS.
AND THEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
THE EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE.
AND THE EXPERTISE OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ORGANIZATIONS.
A.
YOU KNOW THAT HIT HERE.
CONSULTANT INDICATED NINE LIKE
TO READ THAT THIS BUILDS ON THE
LOCAL CAPACITY TO PROMOTE EARLY
DETECTION AND DIAGNOSIS. OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
TO AN EVIDENCE BASED INFORMED ME
BASS.
A PUBLIC OUTREACH INITIATIVE AND
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT IT'S
QUITE SIMPLE.
SO WE RESPECTIVELY REQUEST THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MY NAME IS JACKIE COLEMAN.
A A RP STANDS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS ALZHEIMER'S BUDGET
REQUEST. AND URGES YOUR SUPPORT.
I AM A VOLUNTEER FOR A A RP
CALIFORNIA.
I WAS RECENTLY DIAGNOSED WITH
DEMENTIA.
I HAVE FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE.
WITH HOW IMPORTANT EARLY
DETECTION IS AN ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA IT'S CRITICAL.
IT HAS ALLOWED ME TO PLAN FOR MY
FUTURE.
LEARN ABOUT MY CONDITION.
MAKE LIFESTYLE CHANGES.
AND IT HAS GIVEN ME A NEW LEASE
ON LIFE.
AS I NOW WANT TO SHARE WHAT I'VE
LEARNED WITH OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE RECEIVED A SIMILAR
DIAGNOSIS.
THINKING
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION IN THE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING. AS DIRECTOR TOLD SAID
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT THE FIRST LINE OF
INFORMATION.
FOR PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR SERVICES THE
AREA AGENCY IS THEIR AND
PROVIDES OF INVALUABLE SERVICE.
GIVING THEM THE ADDITIONAL
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS FUNDING WILL
BRING.
TO WORK WITH THE GROWING NUMBER
OF FAMILIES THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE SEEING. I THINK IS
ESSENTIAL SO WE HARDLY ARCH
SUPPORT. BECAME.
PLEASE A COLEMAN WITH CAL COLOR.
WELL YES THE ASSOCIATION IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THIS IS FOR UP
FOR MY FAMILY IT'S A PERSONAL
ISSUE. MY HUSBAND'S AUNT.
.
WHILE SHE HAD SYMPTOMS AND HER
DOCTOR I UNDERSTOOD THAT SHE HAD
SENT HIM SHE NEVER GOT A
DIAGNOSIS.
AND BY THE TIME SHE GOT A
DIAGNOSIS AND FAMILY GOT
INVOLVED I CAME TO VISIT HER TO
FIND ROTTEN FOOD.
BILLS NOT PAID.
MORE THAN A THIRD OF HER
FINANCIAL SAVINGS WAS GONE.
AND I THINK FOR ME IS AN
OMBUDSMAN THE HARDEST PART WAS.
HER COGNITIVE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NEXT STEPS OF
HER LIFE FOR GONE WE CAME TOO
LATE TO ASK HER WHAT IS YOUR
PREFERENCE.
AND SO WHILE I'VE BEEN A PART OF
THE FAMILY FOR THIRTY THREE
YEARS I'VE MET THE WOMAN THREE
TIMES AND I AM NOW FACED WITH.
WELL WHAT DO YOU WANT HOW DO YOU
WANT TO LIVE WHERE YOU WANT TO
LIVE. AND.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN BETTER FOR
HER IT COULD HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN
LESS STRESSFUL FOR THE FAMILY.
IF THERE HAD BEEN GREATER
EMPHASIS ON EARLY DETENTION
DETECTION
SO I DO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
WE CAN.
LARA MILDRED BEFORE I SPEAK MY
COLLEAGUE DEBORAH AUTHORED WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
LOST WHAT WAS LEFT OF HER VOICE
AND HAD TO LEAVE ASKED ME TO
EXPRESS DRC'S STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL. I AM LAUREL
MILDRED I'M HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE AND WE
ALSO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS PROPOSAL WE ARE STILL
BEHIND THE CURVE.
ON THIS ISSUE THE GROWTH OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S POPULATION AS GOING
TO.
BALLOON IN CALIFORNIA IN THE IN
SEVEN YEARS WE EXPECT THAT THIS
POPULATIONS MEDI CAL COSTS WILL
GO UP SIXTY PERCENT.
IT IS SHOCKING.
THAT LESS THAN HALF OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THIS.
DISEASE
ARE TO. THEY ARE BROUGHT TO.
I ALSO FEEL THIS IS VERY
PERSONAL THEY'RE BROUGHT OF
THEIR ABILITY TO EXPRESS WITHIN
HUNT FOR THEIR LIVES
WE'RE.
UNPREPARED
TO HEAR THEM AND COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM ABOUT THE REAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR LIFE SO
THAT THE HE CAN PREPARE AND MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEIR LIKE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
I COMMEND.
WHY CAN'T EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE TRIPLE A OF SANTA CRUZ AND
SAN BENITO COUNTY SAN I WANT TO
ECHO SOME OF THE EARLIER
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED THE
COLLABORATIVE NATURE OF THIS AND
I THINK IT'S?
IN I'VE BEEN UP HERE A LOT TODAY
BUT THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE ALL THESE PROGRAMS DO
RELY ON EACH OTHER TREMENDOUSLY.
AND WE INTERFACE AND MAKE SURE
WE DON'T DUPLICATE THAT LIMITED
SERVICES WE HAVE.
ARM AROUND THIS PROPOSAL MY
INFORMATION ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
IS CONSTANTLY COMMUNICATING TO
ME WE CAN'T DEAL WITH THE AMOUNT
OF CALLS WERE GETTING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHOSE PARENTS HAVE
ALZHEIMER'S OR SOME SORT OF
DEMENTIA. SO THEY ARE JUST
THRILLED THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
CURRENT COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIP. YOU KNOW THANK YOU
SUSAN FOR TAKING LEADERSHIP ON
MAKING THIS HAPPEN AND DONE WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT IT I ALSO JUST
WANT HAVE A LAST CHANCE HAVE
HERE TO SAY. IT'S REALLY A
PLEASURE TO COME HERE WITH
ENGAGE STAFF AND A SPECIAL USE
SPEAKER OUR CHAIR NAM WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE IN
ACTIVE LISTENING O WHAT I WERE
PRESENTED TO YOU PSYCHOSIS.
MISTER CHAIR MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING ALZHEIMER'S GREATER
LOS ANGELES WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF. THE PROPOSAL AND I WANNA
ALSO ECHO HOW IMPORTANT IS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE PROGRAMS
ARE LOOKING AT TODAY.
TO CONTINUE ON SONYA PULL FROM
OVER HERE THEY'RE GONNA POP UP
OVER HERE AND IT'S GOING TO BE
MORE EXPENSIVE. CELTIC
ACKNOWLEDGE RESEARCH RECOVER AS
A STATE IT'S TIME TO START
MAKING IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND
VALUABLE INVESTMENTS WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS HAVE DEMENTIA.
IN THE EARLIER IT CAN BE
DETECTED FOR THEM AND
THEIR-FAMILIES.
IT'S. EASIER TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
CARE FOR THEM IN A PROGRAM LIKE
PACE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR.
NANCY MIRISCH CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
AT A RECENT DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT
A FAMILY MEMBER WAS TOLD BY THE
DOCTOR WHEN THEY EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR MEMORY.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO BE TESTED
FOR THAT THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN
DO?
IF I HAD BEEN SITTING IN THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND IN THE
ADVOCATE THAT I AM HERE TODAY I
WOULD HAVE SAID.
SELF DETERMINATION HE WILL MAKE
DIFFERENT DECISIONS TODAY IF HE
KNOWS THIS IS COMING.
THEN IF HE THINKS EVERYTHING IS
FINE.
THE IDEA THAT NOT TESTING
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE
THIS DIAGNOSIS.
IT'S JUST A WAY TO STICK OUR
HEAD IN THE SAND AND IT DOESN'T
DO ANYONE ANY GOOD THE DIAGNOSIS
IS NEVER EASY TO TAKE FOR THE
PERSON OR THE FAMILY. BUT BEING
UP TO PREPARE FOR IT IS MUCH
EASIER THE EARLIER THAT WE CAN
DO IT. SO I I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU BECAME.
JANET HEATH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND ASSIST BESIDE ASSOCIATION ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
AND TO WEAR ANOTHER HAT.
I'M THE DAUGHTER A NINETY ONE
YEAR OLD WOMAN WITH.
DEMENTIA.
AND.
THANK GOODNESS I LEARNED ABOUT
DEMENTIA AND WILL LOOK LIKE.
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO PUT A
LOT OF THINGS IN PLACE
BEFORE GOT REALLY BAD.
SO WE WENT FROM MOM PUTTING.
CAPT DO DO AND SOME OF HIS CAR
BECAUSE THEY PARKED IN FRONT OF
OUR HOUSE TO.
MOM WERE TAKING OVER ALL YOUR
BILLS WERE DOING YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A CAREGIVER IN THE
HOUSE YOU HAVE A TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY.
SHE'S LIVING AT HOME THIS IS A
THING ABOUT HER ELEVENTH YEAR
SHE'S BEEN LIVING AT HOME WITH
THE GUITAR. ALL THE SUPPORT THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUT IN PLACE
A LOT OF THAT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
EARLY EDUCATION I HAVE.
THINK
BECAME.
DENISE LIKER INDEPENDENCE AT
HOME LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
SO FROM MY FROM THE PROFESSIONAL
SIDE THIS IS KIND OF A NO
BRAINER MY STAFFER OUT THERE IN
THESE HOMES AND TRYING TO TRYING
TO ON EARTH WHAT IS GOING ON.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO FOOD THERE'S
PEOPLE ARE COMPLAINING THAT
THERE THERE'S BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS. THEIR HOW THEY HAVE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS GOING ON.
AND THEY CAN THEY THE EGG THERE
A JACK OF ALL TRADES BUT WE'RE
NOT AN EXPERT IN EVERYTHING AND
HAVING RESOURCES LIKE THIS
AVAILABLE.
MAKES IT THAT MUCH EASIER IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
DIGNITY AND AT IN OUR IN OUR
OLDER AGE.
PERSONALLY MY MOTHER WILL BE
EIGHTY MAY FIFTH
MY MOTHER TO HAS PROGRESSIVE
DEMENTIA ISSUES.
I AM HER CAREGIVER IOM SHIELDS
FIVE MILES FOR ME I AM IT I AM
EVERYTHING I AM THE CHECK BOOK I
AM THE RIDE.
I AM THE ONE THAT HAS TO SAY
KNOW MOM THAT HAPPENED TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY YEARS AGO THEY'RE
NOT COMING TO VISIT YOU.
EVEN AS A PROFESSIONAL WORKING
IN THIS FIELD. I TO NEED
RESOURCES AS WELL IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE MY AND HELP MY
FAMILY MANAGE SO PLEASE. THAT
YOU HEARD TODAY AND EVERYTHING
THEMES OF DIGNITY AN AGING.
CONCURRENT SO THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
MICHELLE POPE BEGAN ALZHEIMER'S
SERVICES OF THE EAST BAY FOR THE
LAST TWENTY ONE YEARS I'VE HAD
THE HONOR OF BEING A SUPPORT
GROUP FACILITATOR FOR CAREGIVERS
AND INDIVIDUALS. ARE LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AS A PASTOR ONCE A
MONTH I FACILITATE A DEMENTIA
FRIENDLY SPECIFIC OF SERVICE FOR
THEM THAT'S THIRTY MINUTES LONG
SO THAT THEY CAN. HAVE SOME
SPIRITUAL AND TOOK IT INTO
CONNECTION IN THEIR LIVES.
EVERY SINGLE CARE GIVER THAT
I'VE EVER WORKED WITH HAS SAID
TO ME.
NO ONE EVER TOLD ME THAT WAS
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE
WITH ALZHEIMER'S OR OTHER FORMS
OF DEMENTIA THEIR PHYSICIANS
DIDN'T KNOW THE SOCIAL WORKERS
DIDN'T KNOW THE THE TERM
DEMENTIA IS EVEN LOWER.
USE INAPPROPRIATELY WITHIN OUR
MEDICAL CONSTRUCT.
AND SO THE NEED FOR THIS
FUNDING TO TRAIN PEOPLE HOW TO
USE THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
WHEN DIAGNOSED.
AS WELL AS LEADING PEOPLE TO
RESOURCE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY TO
KEEP THEM IN THE COMMUNITY AND
TO. KEEP THEIR DIGNITY NOT TAKE
AWAY THEIR DIGNITY JUST BECAUSE
THEY HAVE MEMORY LOSS.
CLEARLY KITANA SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION ALAMEDA COUNTY.
JUST WANNA GO ON A RECORD THAT
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
I COMMEND.
MORRISON MELLOW WITH MEALS ON
WHEELS OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
ALSO AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN. MY
GRANDFATHER TWENTY SIX YEARS AGO
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S
AND I WISH THAT WE HAD HAD THE
RESOURCES OR THE WHERE WITH ALL.
TO CONTACT AND REACH OUT TO THE
SERVICES THAT WE NOW HAVE BUT HE
STILL FINDS THAT EVEN TWENTY SIX
YEARS LATER.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY DO NOT
KNOW THAT THESE RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE SO I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS. FUNDING
AUGMENTATION THANK YOU BECAME.
JOHN PORTER CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE AS WE GROW OLDER THE
RISK OF DEMENTIA INCREASES I
URGE SUPPORT.
OF THIS FUNDING THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUB
COMMENT ALL BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE DYESS
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ARE THERE ANY TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF THIS PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OR FEEDBACK REGARDING.
WE CONCUR WITH THAT BEIJING'S
UM'S
SUGGESTIONS AND CONCERNS WE WILL
WORK WITH PART OF AGING AND
ADVOCATES.
IF NECESSARY GREAT THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIVE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL ISSUE OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CONLEY
.
THAT IF WE CAN HAVE JOHN POINTER
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN POINTER ON THE EXPECTED
DIRECTOR AND CHAIR OF THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE.
I BEFORE YOUR DAY SPEAK TO THE
CSL THREE YEAR FINANCING PLAN.
YOU HAVE EACH RECEIVED A COPY
OF.
THERE WAS THREE ISSUES THE PLAN
WAS TO ADDRESS
CIALIS TAKEN ACTION ON ALL THREE
ISSUES.
AS THE PLAN OUTLINES.
MY PRESENTATION TODAY WILL FOCUS
ON OUR PROPOSED SOLUTION TO
FUNDING SEE YOURSELF FOR THE
FUTURE.
OUR PROPOSALS OUTLINING THE PCP
IT HAS BEEN SUBMITTED TO DEAL
EFFORT FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE PROPOSAL SPEAKS TO A TWO TWO
TIERED FUNDING PROCESS.
FIXED NOT DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES
WILL BE FUNDED USING GENERAL
FUNDS.
DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES COMMONLY
ASSOCIATED WITH CO SOUTH AFRICA
SEE.
AND LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS WILL BE
FUNDED.
FROM THE TAX CHECKOFF PROGRAM.
ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE THREE YOUR
FINANCING PLAN CURRENT AN
ESTIMATED EXPENSES.
ARGENTA FIGHT FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR AS WELL AS
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TO ONE.
THE LETTER TO YOUR SUPPORT TRADE
USING THE TWO TIER FUNDING
SYSTEM.
LET ME BRIEFLY I PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE ISSUE OF
FUNDING.
IN JULY TWENTY FOURTEEN
SEE YOURSELF COMPLETED REPORT.
UNFUNDED CSL THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
THE REPORT WAS A RESULT OF A
CLIENT TAX CHECKOFF DONATIONS IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN.
THE FOCUS WAS ON ADDITIONAL
REVENUE SOURCES.
AS WELL AS IMPROVING DONATIONS
TO SEE A CELL.
TAX CHECKOFF FUND.
WE'VE PURSUED SOME OF THOSE
APPROACHES HOWEVER.
THE CONCLUSION WAS THAT THE TAX
CHECK OFF
IS OUR BEST SOURCE OF FUNDING.
THIS YOURSELF PARTICIPATE IN THE
TAX CHECKOFF SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE.
IT'S BEEN THE PRIMARY FUNDING
TRAIN FOR CO CELL DURING THE
ENTIRE HISTORY AS A STATE
AGENCY.
A HISTORY OF DONATIONS OVER
THREE DECADES HAS BEEN PROVIDED
IN THE THREE YEAR FINANCING
PLAN.
AS THE FINANCING PLAN NOTES.
SOMETHING CHANGED HOWEVER IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
CONTRIBUTIONS FELL TO TO LEARN
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS.
NCSL FELL BELOW THE MINIMUM
CONTRIBUTION AMOUNT CAN NEVER
EXCEEDED.
THAT AMOUNT AGAIN.
FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS
IT ALSO SOUGHT DONATIONS FALL
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT.
FROM TWENTY ELEVEN.
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT.
AND THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
CANNOT TELL US WHY.
DONATIONS OF CONTINUE DEFAULT OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN FIGURE OF SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB FIVE
NINETEEN WHICH RETURN HIMSELF OF
A TAX CHECK OFF.
CFL CONTRACTED WITH A VENDOR.
WITH A NINETY FOUR PERCENT PAST
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION RATIO
WITHOUT AND BRADSTREET.
TO DEVELOP AN AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
DURING THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TAX PROVINCE.
JANUARY PAPER RESULTS ARE
AVAILABLE AND WE'RE PROJECTING
DONATIONS FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR.
WILL BE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND.
SO WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
SO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY BUT WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS.
I LIKED TO NEXT SPEAK TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS PROPERTY.
THE OUT.
UP GOING TO MORE TAP YOU'RE
JUST A SECOND LAST YEAR ABOUT
THIS TIME.
YOU MISTER CHAIR DIRECTED DEAL
F. NCSL.
FIND A SOLUTION
FUNDING CSL.
THE EFFORTS OF A TEAM OF CFL
DEAL OFTEN ALEJO RESULTED IN
SOME SAVINGS AND STREAMLINING
ORGANIZATIONAL. AND PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES.
IT DID NOT FIND A SOLUTION TO
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM.
AND THAT HEALTH FITNESS FIXED
COSTS THAT MAKE UP.
CMP ASSN PRO RATA.
FEES AND SALARY AND BENEFITS.
CFL WAS FACED WITH THE FOLLOWING
SIXTY NINE PERCENT.
CSL PROJECTED EXPENDITURES AND
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN OR STATE
FEES.
AS WELL AS SALARY AND BENEFITS
EACH YEAR THE CITY'S TAKEN EVER
INCREASING PORTION OF THE CSL
BUDGET AS DEMONSTRATED IN THE
TABLE. ON PAGE FIVE WITH A THREE
YEAR FINANCING PLAN.
FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIVE
YEARS
CMP ES HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED.
IF THIS TREND CONTINUES IMPROVE
THE NPS IS PROJECTED TO DOUBLE
AGAIN.
WITHIN THAT WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
THESE FEES ARE COMPLYING WITH
SALARY AND BENEFITS SIMPLY
CONSUME.
THE BUDGET OF CSL IN THE FUTURE
THE SOLUTION.
THE CHALLENGE RAISING DONATIONS
TO STAY AHEAD.
OF THESE CONTINUALLY ESCALATING
FEES
HE COMES OVERWHELMING.
SEE YOURSELF.
NO ORGANIZATION CAN SURVIVE ON
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING THAT IS
TO CONTINUE THIS CLAWING EACH
SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
SO THE SENIOR FELLOW SUBMITTED A
PCP.
ARE THAT SPEAKS TO CMP* AS
WELL AS PRO RATA.
AND TALKS TO PERMIT STATE
EMPLOYEE SALARY AND BENEFITS.
AS I OUT NOTED EARLIER TALKS THE
FIXED
NON DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES.
AND ALSO DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES
ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE THREE YEAR
FINANCING PLAN. CURRENT
ESTIMATED EXPENSES ARE GONNA
FIGHT AS I'VE ALREADY NOTED FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
SO WHAT ARE FIX NON
DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES AS I
NOTED EARLIER SALARY AND
BENEFITS.
IT ALSO STATE FEES.
M. THE THREE YEAR PLAN
SALARY AND BENEFITS JUST HAVE
RISEN BUT THEY'VE RISEN BECAUSE
OF.
STEPPING PRIESTS IS COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS AND THE
INCREASE IN THE COST OF
BENEFITS.
STATE FEES
WERE FORTY THREE THOUSAND.
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE DOLLARS.
TWENTY ELEVEN TWELVE.
THEY OUR ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTY DOLLARS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
WE'RE PROJECTING MAYES COSTS
WILL CONTINUE TO ESCALATE IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
DISCRETIONARY EXPENSES INVOLVE
OPERATING COSTS THAT'S INVOLVED
PRINTING POSTAGE.
COMMUNICATION INSURANCE IT
CETERA
AND EMISSIONS ESSENTIAL TASKS
ARE REALLY WHAT OUR CORE MISSION
IS. AND THAT'S INVOLVED WITH
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
AND IN THE PROCESS INVOLVES
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS ARE
REVIEWED IT SUBMITTED IN JUNE
THE ANNUAL SESSION CONDUCTED
OCTOBER EACH YEAR'S IDENTIFIES
OUR TOP TEN. AND FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM WE SHOPPED THOSE TOP
TEN LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS DURING
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
CONCLUSION.
SO IN CONCLUSION.
CSL IS TAKEN A NUMBER STEPS TO
ADDRESS REVENUE EXPENSES.
WE HAVE STREAMLINED SOME
PROCESSES
AND WE SEE IMPROVEMENT TAX CHECK
OFF.
HOWEVER AS I NOTED IT.
EARLIER THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
IS STATE FEES.
THE REALITY IS THAT SEE US OUT
IN RETURN DONATIONS TO PRE
TWENTY THIRTEEN LEVELS.
AND ALWAYS SEE NON DISCRETIONARY
SPENCER'S CONSUME MORE AND MORE
THE BUDGET EACH YEAR.
SO OUR INTENT IS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF
FROM INCREASING FIX NON
DISCRETIONARY COSTS OR EXPENSES.
THAT NOW REPRESENT SIXTY NINE
PERCENT OF SEE YOURSELF
EXPENDITURES
SINCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
STIR JOINT RULES COMMITTEE CHAIR
AS WELL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO.
YES WE ARE KERN REFUSING THESE
PROPOSALS BY THE SPRING BUDGET
PROCESS SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO SHARE AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS IF I CAN.
FIRST OF ALWAYS BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH THE PROPOSAL'S MISTER
POINTER THAT YOU BRING FORWARD
CAN YOU LIST A FEW OF THE
LEGISLATIVE VICTORIES THAT
YOU'VE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
ARE.
LET ME LET ME SUMMARIZE THEM ARE
A COUPLE OF THE COUPLE HERE
QUICKLY MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
ESP ONE FORTY SEVEN.
ALLOWS A HOMEOWNER TO. DESIGNATE
ONE OTHER PERSON
TO SHARE MOBILE HOME. THEIR
MOBILE HOME WITHOUT A FEE
INCREASE.
AB.
X. TO FIFTEEN.
END OF LIFE.
I DON'T THINK THAT NEEDS ANY
ADDITIONAL EXPLANATION.
AB SIX FORTY THREE SILVER ALERT.
THE EQUIVALENT OF AMBER ALERT.
AB NINE EIGHTEEN EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES.
TO MOBILIZE AND EVACUATE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IN EACH
COMMUNITY.
ARE.
AND THEN THERE'S A NUMBER HERE
INVOLVING ELDER ABUSE AND
IDENTITY THEFT.
OUR A BEACH SIX TWENTY SIX
TWENTY THREE A. B..
THIRTY THREE THIRTY TWO AND THEN
AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT ELDER
ECONOMIC PLANNING THAT.
REQUIRED A STATE PLAN ON AGING.
TO UTILIZE AN ELDER INDEX AS A
REFERENCE AND. ESTIMATING COSTS
OF.
BASIC NEEDS.
I ALSO HAVE AND WILL BE HAPPY TO
SEND TO.
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF A SUMMARY OF
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN INTO LAW. THAT
GO ON THE WAY BACK TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO GREAT I.
I HAVE ALWAYS APPRECIATED THE
COMMITMENT INVOICE THAT YOU ADD
ON TO OUR BODY HERE.
AND SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A CAN A SUGGESTION FOR
CONSIDERATION HERE.
WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER ABSORBING THE ONE
POSITION AND AND IT WOULD COME
WITH FUNDING FOR ASSOCIATED
COSTS.
CURRENTLY STAFFING THE CSL INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
IT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD MUCH TIME YEAH I'M
TO REALLY HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT.
BUT JUST KIND OF AT A HIGH
LEVEL.
.
A ONE OF THE AREAS I THINK IN
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THE MISSION
OF CSL.
IT'S FAIRLY CLICK VERY CLEARLY
FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING
LEGISLATION.
.
FORMULATING THAT SHOPPING IT AS
YOU WERE IN THE TERM THAT YOU
USE TO THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTLY.
THAT IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
WAY WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WE WORK ON LEGISLATION AND
THE VARIOUS STEPS THAT WE GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
IN TERMS OF EVEN IF IT ISN'T
ADMINISTRATION SPONSORED BILL
AND WORKING WITH.
WITH LEGISLATORS AND COMMITTEES
SO.
UP I HAVE JUST SOME KIND OF AT A
HIGH LEVEL CONCERNED ABOUT ROLE
CONFUSION OR WHERE. YOU KNOW HOW
WOULD WHAT WE MIGHT DO IN THAT.
CAPACITY DIFFER FROM WHAT
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES IS
CURRENTLY DOING AND TERMS OF
JUST STRAIGHT. ADMIN SUPPORT.
FOUR CSL.
IN TERMS OF THOSE IN TERMS OF
THAT WORK AND WHAT THE WHAT THE
VALUE ADDED IS.
AND KEEPING THE INDEPENDENCE OF
CSL. AND AS
I'M IN GOOD KEEPING WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF
PROPHECIES.
JUST START OUT. THERE THIS WAS A
QUESTION ASKED IN THE SRL IN IT
IF THERE WAS ANY DEPARTMENT THAT
COULD DO THIS AND. I UNDERSTAND
THAT NO DEPARTMENT STEPPED UP.
CDA FEELS LIKE THE.
NATURAL PLACE I.
THEY GOT THAT AGING IN OUR NAY.
WELL IS THE FUNDING WITH THE
POSITION THE KEY ISSUE HERE YOU
REALLY FEEL LIKE IT'S THE
INDEPENDENCE. THE WHAT IT IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDING OF THE
POSITION.
IF IT WERE JUST DOING THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK. AND IN A
SENSE IN A WAY IT SEEMS.
CLEANER.
JUST IN TERMS OF THE
INDEPENDENCE IF IT CONTINUED TGS
NOW I'M SPEAKING TOTALLY YOU
KNOW OFF THE.
THE CHART HERE IN TERMS OF JUST.
AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION.
.
ONCE IT COMES IN TO THE TO YOU
KNOW WORK TO COME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
IN TERMS OF THE LEGISLATIVE WORK
THAT WE DO.
WHERE IS THE WORST TECH
RADIATION BEGAN AND TERMS HAVE?
MICHAEL ASSISTANCE.
THE M. THE INDEPENDENCE KIND OF
THE FIREWALL BETWEEN ONE
ORGANIZATION AND THE OTHER SO
THAT THAT'S JUST KIND OF HIGH
LEVEL. THINKING.
NOT AND OTHERS I HAVE HAD IF I
CAN I WE DON'T NEED A FINAL
ANSWER TODAY BUT IF THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY FOR US TO ENGAGE IN
THIS DISCUSSION.
IT'S COUPLE FOR US TO CONSIDER
AND. NAM AGAIN IT'S JUST A
SUGGESTION BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A
NATURAL SATIN ONE THAT WE'D LIKE
TO CONTINUE SOME.
ROGER CHAIR. OF FIRST THAT I
APOLOGIZE FOR PLACING YOU IN THE
HOT SEAT HERE TODAY UP. OF THAT
THE KIDS IN ON PATTERSON TO.
MY BACKGROUND IS THIRTY SIX
YEARS IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AT.
I DIDN'T WORK IN WASHINGTON DC
BUT I HAD A TOP LEVEL POSITION.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE SO I'VE GOT SOME EXPERIENCE
NO ONE.
WANTS TO BE.
ARE UNLOADED ON IT I'VE BEEN IN
THAT CHAIR MYSELF AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN THE. YOU WANT DO WHAT.
MENTALITY SEEPS IN IMMEDIATELY
UP
BUT PERHAPS
IF WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
DOWN AND AND.
AND INTERACT AND HAVE SOME
DISCUSSION MAYBE THERE ARE SOME
COMMON GROUND MAYBE WAS SIMPLY
CHECK THAT'S WHAT OFFICE WELL
AS.
THAT'S NOT AN OPTION. ARE
EITHER.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO TRY AND
PURSUE THIS AND I WILL BE BACK
HERE NEXT YEAR ARE IF NECESSARY
ORDER TO FIND THE SOLUTION TO
THE FUNDING. BUT PERHAPS THAT
MIGHT BE ONE OPTION A WE MIGHT
LOOK AT.
AS WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WITH THAT A THAT WILL WE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND THAT
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU ALL FOR ATTENDING.
YOU.
MAKING IT ALL INCOME